committee I find that due to the state
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically these are presentations
pres pertaining to the capital budget
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information
has been been made available in the
house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and with RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.
.n. Us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled I would
like to introduce the staff that are on
the meeting assisting us Brad Greenland
committee researcher and Christopher
Shay please note that all votes taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll call
vote let us start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when each when
each member states their pres please
also State whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
law Mr
clerk thank you Mr chairman
representative Graham president in the
committee room representative makoni
presid in the committee room
representative Mills is here and in the
committee room representative
samaro represent SoMo
representative
faly representative
folie representative
Newton representative
blazic representative
boards representative
bors representative kazinski
representative
kazinski representative
Thompson presid in the meeting room
representative Vandy
Castillo representative Vandy
Castillo representative cluder uh pres
in the committee
room representative Edgar president at
home uh Kathy might be around
someplace representative evil home alone
in New London good to see you
all representative Jack president in the
committee
room representative Abbot dear in the
committee room representative
fauler I'm here at home and Swansea uh
alone for the moment but my wife will be
home
soon representative
Newman yes here in nashaa alone in the
room my husband is in the house on
another committee meeting
representative
Eaton representative
Peterson representative
s present at home in Manchester
alone representative
bunker I am present at home my wife may
pass through from time to time
thank
you um okay thank you sorry if
um thank you Mr clerk at this point uh
the first presentation today will be
from the Department of Agriculture
markets and food and I believe I see the
commissioner is online with us if we
could bring him up at this point
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh thank you commissioner for
coming was there anybody else that you
needed to bring with you I'm hopeful
that uh Gail McWilliams jelly
is on uh online here somewhere but I'm
not sure I have not spoken with her this
morning okay Rim Graham she is and we'll
bring her into the meeting this is Chris
all right thank you very much Mr Shay
all right commissioner um you have your
periodic requests for the
big yes um and I I know you have all of
our information so I I would prefer to
to answer questions um rather than bore
you with details of things you already
have in in front of you obviously the
last uh last year was a difficult one we
did not um open the building the eastern
states Exposition did not go forward and
we're unsure of what is going to happen
and in the meantime the uh the building
continues to uh to needs to be
maintained many years ago uh former
commissioner Taylor set up a uh
organization called uh champions of New
Hampshire New Hampshire Farms they
largely run the um exhibits within the
building and they they have run uh
things like the uh a booth to do lobster
macaroni and cheese and and raise funds
much of the money that they they raise
is put right back into the buildings so
a lot of the maintenance is is done that
way obviously they raised no money last
year so periodically we do need to come
forward and ask for um monies for from
the state to maintain the building and I
think pictures and in these cases truly
do speak a thousand words the the one
thing that you really can't tell from
the pictures uh is the issue of the fire
escape while it looks like it's well
maintained it does not meet current
codes and we have a dorm room on the top
floor of the building and that is the
emergency exit and um while we were
largely left alone by Massachusetts when
it came to build buing codes they have
recently started to come down on us we
have a number of issues with the dorm
room we're not asking for any assistance
and dealing with with those but um one
of the things we absolutely need is to
bring our fire escape um to code and you
can see the the other issues with the
deterioration of the exterior of the
building that we're uh we're dealing
with so with that I'd be glad to answer
any questions commissioner we have a lot
of new members
on this committee uh if you could just
take a minute or so to explain why we
owed a building in
massach fair fair enough so um the
eastern states Exposition is really a
one of a kind in in the country it is a
fair run by all New England states
through a non nonprofit which um all
states have trustees that uh are respons
responsible for that and over a period
of time beginning in the 1920s each New
England State built a building to
represent their state and have exhibits
within those those buildings and they're
all in a in a row they're beautiful
buildings and um we showcase New
Hampshire products in those buildings so
um you have some of that in your
materials but um for many of our vendors
it's a huge part of their annual income
because there's a million five people
coming through the fair now uh each each
year and um it's really a a
great time for for everyone but it's a
huge uh fundraiser and this is is
something we should be proud of and we
should maintain our building and and
right now we're not doing a very good
job of that obviously the building is
now over 90 years old and um has has
been fairly wellmaintained but you can
really see the deterioration of the of
the pointing and the chimneys are are
leaning and need to be brought down and
and built up up again but
um it is it is a a unique event in the
in the
country and it it
um the the I remember my first term that
was my basic question of why are we
spending money in
Massachusetts uh hopefully that will do
it um is the the dollar
amount within the
um um Governor's proposal and what is it
will be in House Bill 25 sufficient to
do those repairs that you talked about
we we believe that it is um you know
prices prices change but um we do
believe that we will be able to um to do
that and there are a couple of lower
priced items items here that if perhaps
there isn't we might still have the
ability to work with the champions of
New Hampshire Farms to get these these
things done um I can't guarantee that
but we we believe this will will
accomplish our
goals any questions of
um the um commissioner or his staff
about uh this uh project that is
included in hospital
25 representative
eil thank you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner um could you talk about the
faux chimneys I I gather they're part of
the stylistic uh appearance of the
building and that's why they have to be
replaced yes they are um you know I I
don't know a lot of of the history as
you can see the building was built to be
a replica of the original state house um
and I assume that that is part of it and
certainly removing those would
substantially change the the look of of
the building and so I would certainly
not recommend removing them and not
replacing them I think it would it would
be a real detriment to the to the
architecture of the building thank
you um representative Newman yes thank
you commissioner
do you have an estimate of what the fire
escape repairs alone would
be uh yes that's
$25,000 okay thank
you representative AB yes thank you Mr
chairman commissioner I would assume
that the the fire escape would be the
number one
priority is that yeah I I think it
probably is
um Gail might be able
to um speak to that although you know I
I think it will be some years before
those chimneys might be in danger of
toppling over you you can see that those
could become a safety uh a safety
concern because they are are leaning and
um at some
point that could be a safety concern but
I think without the uh fire escape being
brought up to code we would be in danger
of not being able to have the workers
stay there um and that is a a huge part
of of how we are able to operate the
building is to use that bunk room and
have those the people who come in and
are permanent workers really working for
the champions of New Hampshire Farms to
be able to uh to stay there overnight
because obviously wouldn't be able to
afford that if we had to put people up
in U in motels and hotels so
any other questions of the commissioner
or his staff Mr chairman uh
representative CL thank you and I'm
commissioner and I know that the
chairman alluded to this about because
periodically the agriculture Department
comes in with a requests for this
building do you remember when the last
capital budget there was a request for
this building and you have any idea what
it was for it's a brief description and
if not like maybe someone on the staff
but I I think Gail could probably answer
that I don't believe that we had
requested anything in my first budget so
I I will defer to Gail on that okay
right thank youer yes good morning um I
believe it was under commissioner Merill
so probably 10 or so years ago and I
believe the main request was for roof
repair to the
building all right thank you appreciate
that information
and unfortunately I remember that far
back any other questions of the
department seeing none commissioner we
thank you for for appearing and uh um
providing all the um uh paper
electronically to the members of the
committee if we have any other questions
we do know how to get a hold of you very
good I thank you for your for your time
and your consideration have a good
day same
te and moving right along to the next
presentation is is from the judicial
branch
and I believe that Justice Hicks is here
to represent the the judicial branch I
am and it's a pleasure to be here can
everyone hear me yes and welcome to the
committee Justice Hi Well thank thank
you very much uh thank you chairman
Graham Vice chairman mcon and members of
the House Public Works committee I'm
Gary Hicks senior associate Justice of
the New Hampshire Supreme Court that the
next time you hear from us chances are
will be my new boss Gordon McDonald who
will be sworn in on Friday I on Thursday
but joining me today are my colleagues
Chris keading the director of the
administrative office of the Courts
Donna Raymond our fiscal manager Matt
Sean our Chief Information officer and
Jackie Waters our New Hampshire ecourt
program director we're here to present I
want to make sure I get framed correctly
we're here to present uh our request for
Capital funding for the New Hampshire
ecourt Project New Hampshire ecourt as
some of you know is the New Hampshire
Branch's singular and comprehensive
Technology Innovation program we will
explain why to those who uh don't
already know why it is essential to New
Hampshire citizens to share with you uh
our successes we will explain how we
will strategically utilize Capital funds
in the upcoming bium our
presentations uh after our presentation
we're prepared to answer uh any
questions the branch is requesting $1.4
million of capital funds to continue the
ecort project it's a technical program
that reduces procedural barriers and
increases access to Justice through
Modern software and Hardware examples
include electronic filing for attorneys
and self-represented litigants online
access to case documents automated
workflow for staff and attorneys and
judges managing mostly the paperless
court that we now find ourselves in
never has the properly applied use of
Technology proven to be more beneficial
to New Hampshire citizens than during
the pandemic and we can provide examples
of that our presentation will
demonstrate that value the know
historically the New Hampshire in court
project began in 2012 uh I was there so
I have a memory of it every year since
the New Hampshire judicial branch has
delivered Technology Solutions on time
and on budget the program has been
recognized nationally as a model for
supporting self-represented litigants in
their transition from paper to paperless
firing most importantly we will share
datadriven metrics that demonstrate New
Hampshire e-c Court's value to litigants
and other
parties as with any technology New
Hampshire ecourt continues to evolve our
objective is to continue advancing as
rapidly as new and better Solutions
become available your support through a
capital appropriation has always been
appreciated and it will yet again enable
the New Hampshire Branch to keep modern
technology in our access to Justice
toolkit and if there are no other the
questions specific questions of me at
this time I will turn over the mic to
Jackie Waters the New Hampshire ecourt
program
director I would ask the committee to
hold all of your questions so we've
heard the entire presentation we
probably go little
SM thank you
sir Jackie are you there yes I am thank
you justice Hicks I appreciate that um
can everyone hear
me yes okay well thank you thank you for
this opportunity again my name is Jackie
Waters the New Hampshire ecort program
director and I have been working on New
Hampshire ecort since the beginning in
2012 as Justice 6 mentioned we're
requesting $1.4 million to expand eort
following the NH Court 2.0 strategic
plan this is a plan focused um on areas
of continuous Improvement to complete
some strategic initiatives that improve
access to Justice and to build out the
technical infrastru structure that
supports the modern technology required
by government
entities I'm I'm following along on the
slides I assume that you've all received
them that I've just covered on the
titles moving to the second
slide excuse me I just get my computer
to work okay so what is the purpose of
New Hampshire EC Court um you know why
do we even do this so really as you can
see in the New Hampshire digal Branch
Mission we believe in access to justice
for all and the New Hampshire EC cor
program exists so that modern technology
can facilitate this Mission we believe
that the prudent use of technology to
ensure the court system remains a viable
and relevant dispute resolution form
that serves New Hampshire fairly and
independently moving to the next
slide so how does the New Hampshire
ecourt help people during the pandemic
we couldn't of course have this
presentation without this mentioning the
pandemic um I feel believe that it they
this situation offers an actually unique
opportunity to demonstrate how ecourt
supports the judicial branches Mission
even during these most challenging times
so for example electronic filing means
people do not need to come into the
courthouse to conduct their Court
business fewer visitors means more
effective social distancing and lowers
covid-19 exposure risk and also two
court operations are not not at this
time tightly bound to court facilities
so remote working and remote hearings
are
possible and calling your attention to
some of the data points uh since the
pandemic in the Superior Court nearly
11,000 cases have been e filed and
almost 24,000 cases in the Circuit
Court I think it's important to know
about remote working um when they uh uh
Court process is electronic you can more
easily reallocate staff and judges when
quarantine and illness impact our
staffing levels so reallocating work
among the staff has been a great benefit
provided by
ecort so slide number four what is eort
some of you may not be as familiar with
uh the program as others I think of it
in three in three categories it's first
it's a technology platform this platform
automates adjudication processes that
are administered by the judicial
branch it is also a set of
software-based services these include
electronic filing and electronic service
online document access for case parties
and others and it also includes guided
interviews to help self-represented
litigant to prepare their pleadings
you've heard of um turbo court or turbox
I'm sure it's similar to that and
answering questions um results in a
properly formatted ple in for electronic
filing and finally eort is also a
strategic management approach we focus
on providing substantial benefits by
optimizing our resources and one that I
refer to as the small But Mighty team
and rather deploying deploying just
disperate point Solutions so our goal is
to ensure that the whole is greater than
some of its parts as we deploy
technology some people like pictures so
I decided to put a conceptual diagram of
ecort uh into their presentation and
very briefly um this is an idea that uh
looking on the left side of the diagram
of course eort is internet based what
isn't these days we have our
constituents our self- represent Lans
attorneys Justice Partners um we also
have vendors M much of our ecort
technology platform is hosted in the
government Cloud the S secure government
cloud and um if they questions about
that I'm sure we can Mac and answer them
for you the um middle it's always the
security layer right cyber security um
General Network traffic making sure it's
safe and secure and then on the other
side of that secure wall is are are the
staff and the judges who are working
every day um and in the gray box on the
very far right side those represent our
Enterprise systems the aicy case
management system product called judge
judge Judges Bench uh which is for hand
L documents during um hearings and then
finally case party access to their uh
file
documents so what are the benefits of an
electronic Court in EC
specifically so you can see there's some
of the some of the benefits I've listed
um so every every initiative that we
Implement is with with is excuse me is
with the intent to consistently deliver
and improve upon the solutions that
makes to judicial branch more effective
in its critical
role we Endeavor to remove physical and
process
barriers our solution should build trust
in in our systems over time it should
support and litigant engagement to
ensure Fair
outcomes and they provide a level of
transparency that's required under law
and finally we Endeavor to maximize the
available resources in the judicial
branch
so eort by the numbers um I'm very proud
to say and and the team that I work with
has delivered a successful project on
time and every on budget every year
since
2012 over 136,000 cases have been filed
representing about 1.8 million
documents and again we've completed
about 13 projects virtually one every
year since
2012 so we've used the generous funding
that we we have received prudently and
effectively for eight years we have
never had a failed
project an important metric that many
look at when they're talking about court
operations this is a time to disposition
so we have some preco numbers there and
we have some data that show an 8 to 72%
decrease in the time to
disposition uh for several of the
Circuit Court e filed cases case
types I also wanted to call out 1.8
million uh electronic documents I
decided to do sort of a backof the
envelope calculation on that so that's
millions of sheets of paper not
purchased not printed mailed filed
stored archived shredded or sent to
landfills so the ecort has helped during
the courts during the pandemic but of
course ecourt was impacted by the
pandemic and we responded in in a manner
that I refer to as the pandemic pivot so
the projects we had intended for fiscal
year 2021 are on hold at the
moment that said with a significant in
fact I would say driving support from
the IT department projects were
delivered uh or are in progress in
response to the emergency orders that Co
um presented to us we created a mobile
Workforce by substantially improving our
virtual private Network and we allocated
laptops and related Hardware to staff
and judges who did not have them we also
launched virtual court so we introduced
WebEx providing software and training to
attorneys judges Court staff filers and
we're in the process of building what we
call WebEx mobile units these are
purpose-built devices that enable video
conferencing with
ease uh so far there are we have spent
more than 12,000 hours on video
conferencing and we've that has is
involved over 77,000
participants so the courts continue to
op operate in part uh because the core
can more easily manage electronic
cases uh I just also wanted to comment I
um that the uh additional Hardware
required was funded with the coronavirus
relief um funds from the cares
act so why does the New Hampshire eor
program require additional Capital funds
well as I've mentioned and shown in my
picture that there ecort is
infrastructure and infrastructure
requires maintenance it requires uh to
be added new
capabilities and it needs to evolve as
technology involves I Envision it very
much as a technology as a tangible asset
and failure to invest in technology
creates something we refer to as
technology debt a status quo in
technology actually means moving
backward and if you want to catch up and
move forward trying to get pasture being
technically obsolete you have to pay
what's called technical debt so future
technology expenditures are always more
costly uh to remedy obsolescent so
keeping um current is
critical moving on to slide 10 how would
we invest the $1.4 million should you
approve its
appropriation well we have a three-point
plan it's a multi-year plan and the
first two require the capital funding
new software solutions for example to
help uh litigants understand legal
issues to help them pay fines to access
Court case information more securely and
conveniently to find ways to settle
disputes fairly with greater ease and
less time and to reduce tangible
expenses we also uh require funding to
prepare for the future now in a future
by anym our intent is to procure a more
modern and flexible cases management
system that type of Endeavor re requires
preparation and we would like to do that
in fiscal year
23 then we also have a third component
of the plan of the plan worthy
mentioning um we we have to maintain our
systems that's not a capital expenditure
but maintaining systems is a critical
component of our
plan and finally this isn't um the last
picture it's a little bit updated from
the first one and you can see it looks
very much much the same we have our
constituents our litigant and our
Justice Partners but we also have
expanded our our presence in the
government cloud and uh we intend um to
have more solutions hosted by our
vendors in this secure environment and
on the side where we have our uh
internal staff working we um are
deploying what we call an Enterprise
service bus and this is a technology
that helps um move information and
workflows more uh fluidly and more
rapidly than using many many separate um
software
applications so we um believe that we
have a proven track record of success
and have demonstrated proper stewardship
of the resources We Touch people's lives
every single day in ways that make a
challenging time in people's lives a
little bit easier and we believe and we
know that modern technology is is a
modern government is is not a luxury um
it's an actually essential service now
and the only technology resources
available to the digital branch is the
capital funding that we
receive and so thank you for this
opportunity to tell you our cour story
um there are details in the appendix
that I encourage you to review and at
this time um we're taking any questions
and um I will facilitate um if I cannot
answer the colleagues here surely can
thank you
um questions uh representative
bunker hi Miss Waters um thank you for
taking my question um I'm new to the
committee so um forgive me if I make
stupid assumptions or anything um I am
curious um and I realize covid may make
this more complicated too but pre
pandemic what percentage approximately
of total court case load is now handled
by eort and how is that trending over
time and is there some sort of Maximum
percentage that it could someday
reach that's a that's an excellent
question so um as of
2020 100% of the sup Supreme Court and
100% of the excuse me Superior Court
cases are e filed with some exceptions
there are some exceptions um we allow an
an exception for people who are unable
to to electronically file the circuit
courts a bit less than that we have some
of the larger case types to complete for
E filing these are the case types
involving Family Matters juvenile
matters and so forth the most
confidential and highly sensitive Court
matters are not yet e filing if I had to
uh roughly estimate I'd say about a
third of the circuit court cases are
electronically filed but I if a precise
number is of of critical importance of
course I can get that for
you uh thank you no just curiosity
followup Mr chair uh yes um so is the is
the eventual goal to have 100% eiling
for all types of cases as or as close as
possible yes I would say the eventual
goal is to do that um right now our
Ambitions are further ahead than the
technology available to us again men in
that security um but yes it would be the
intention of nearly 100 I don't want to
say um 100% there are probably some
matters that just do not even lend
themselves to electronic
filing thank
you uh representative
Faulkner uh yes thank
you you have to unmute yourself Barry
yeah there we go thank you uh say full
disclosure I'm a frequent user of the E
file and can attest to its benefits I
also appreciates your differentiation
between investment and ongoing
maintenance that's another issue that
we've often uh dealt with and I
appreciate your understanding
that Capital Investments can't just be a
replacement for ongoing
maintenance follow on you have an
estimate of how long this particular
particular investment might what what's
the economic lifetime of this investment
and when and will we expect to have a
major new investment program sometime in
the future or is this uh we're trying to
relate our
investment to the uh Bond the length of
time that we have bonds outstanding and
I just was wondering whether this is
like a 10 year or 20y year economic
life um
I I feel like I have only a Layman's
answer to that question I don't know if
Donna could answer or Matthew could
answer from the from my um fiscal
perspective or technology perspective I
can't answer the quick question about um
the uh future investment um we we're
strongly advocating for replacement of
our case management system and we can go
into much more detail about that I don't
have any details today to share with you
about but that would be um a a
significant um a more significant
investment than perhaps we've made in
request for in the past but that's a
several years at least three or four
years
out um anyone to answer about the
economic
lifetime
um Matt
Donna M sh your sh your crystal ball
with us um yes uh representative fauler
uh hi Matthew seeden uh the judicial
branch CIO um you know some of these
are very large institutional
applications and I would say you're
typically looking at a lifespan of about
15 years um a good example is our
current case management system since
procurement to the possible replacement
uh in the future possibly
2024 um it it will have we've had been
with that product for about 15 years um
and not just in government but if you
look in the private sector large
investments into Enterprise you know
resource planning systems um they
typically have a lifespan about 15 years
before you look at a new major
investment in replacing that you of
course during that time we're constantly
taking new releases bug fixes patches um
but yeah at a certain point you have to
replace the entire platform um so I
would say for large software Investments
you're looking at about 15 years
um Hardware much different story um you
know software really drives the
innovation of Hardware uh and not vice
versa Hardware ends up you know
depending on what type of device it is
you could have Hardware such as cell
phones and tablets you know honestly
those are like on a two-year replacement
cycle um it's almost the smaller the
device the more often you have to
replace it then you get into laptops
they usually have a four to five year
useful lifespan desktop computers 6 to S
years
servers um you know the back end of
infrastructure slightly longer again
probably you know between six and eight
years Network networking equipment about
the same you have a useful lifespan
about seven years on those so in this
case most the vast majority of this
request is going to software so if
you're trying to put an economic you
know um impact on it as far as the
length of time I would estimate about 15
years
um 10 to 15 is probably the appropriate
I would not go over
15 thank you for that
answer thank you any other questions I
do have
one
uh understanding that you're are a
separate branch of government has this
um system been coordinated with the
State's Department of Information
Technology to make sure that we're all
compatible with what
doing short answer is yes but I think
someone should provide the technical
answer do you
Matt uh thank you for the question um
yeah we do have Integrations where we do
share information electronically with um
Department of Safety um you
know are our systems exact ly the same
no they're they're using a completely
different record management system than
we are but through the we call it the J1
switch um which is basically a an API or
an integration layer we can send and
receive data between our two systems um
you know the judicial branch it is we're
I like to think of us as extremely very
good neighbors with doit we participate
in um their cyber security uh advisory
committee we're members of the kick um I
have regular monthly meetings with
commissioner goule um so we're very much
partners and we do discuss regularly
what both uh the executive branch it is
working on in the judicial branch we
want to ensure that our we have the
capabilities to partner with each other
whenn
appropriate thank you um like I said I
did understand that you're a separate
Branch but it does help if we could talk
between the three branches of government
and we do so yes representative evil you
have your hand
up I actually had exactly the same
question about coordination among the
diff uh with with doit so thank you
thank you any other
questions yes thank you Mr chairman and
um you sp you spoke at length about the
the effect of the pandemic on the ecort
and one of the things and the bullet
points you have is about eiling for
abuse and neglect chins petitions
Juvenile and adoption cases um I I
certainly would think that given the
trend that
uh because of the reporting agencies
that the number um of these cases would
have declined during the pandemic and
once we resemble or resume The New
Normal that you
would be be seeing a significant
increase is that correct or am I
wrong um that's an excellent question
one that doesn't fall into my area of
expertise um who who um Justice hick do
you have any thoughts about abuse
neglect um volume just to to start out
with um those are the least Pleasant
cases in our system as you no doubt can
appreciate um and we FastTrack every one
of them uh the legislature has supported
us in that endeavor in the past um we
don't have any hard statistics from
which to extrapolate what an increase
might be but we certainly know
anecdotally that they are down and they
are likely in fact to go up so I think
you're right on Target that we will
receive an increase in that type of case
and
litigation representative
Thomas yes um Justice H uh I have a
couple of questions um what point do you
think that you'll be phasing back into
inperson or is this just the future of
the CT system um that very good question
we've learned a lot of benefits uh from
this type of operation there are lawyers
who appear before us from all around the
country who are very happy that they
don't have to charge their client to get
on an airplane and fly 2,000 miles to
appear before our court I I'm going to
be around here for two and a half more
years so I'm probably going to be the
one involved in that decision and uh we
we think our current thinking is keep in
mind that uh Chief McDonald has started
yet and he's going to be the boss our
current thinking is that if parties want
to go remotely and agree to go remotely
that we continue to go remotely now I
did happen to speak to Gordon yesterday
and he U expressed a strong preference
for resuming in-person operations as
soon as we can so I guess I've just
given you two different answers to that
question well thank you very much for
the answer um I guess follow follow up
please Mr chairman
um if that's the way it probably will
run what would you
foresee would you foresee there being
two separate systems operating at the
same time an online system with yes I
do yes I do I don't think we can go back
I mean um there are huge benefits to the
system that you and I are engaged in
right now for example when we have bar
admission ceremonies or award Ceremonies
for Lifetime employees uh friends and
relatives can view from Alaska and
California uh and otherwise participate
and we get a lot of very positive
feedback it's been a very I think uh
Chris keading was the one who first
noticed it it's been uh a very positive
uh employee relations tool for us um so
I think it's not that there's two
different systems there's two parallel
systems thank you very much thank you
thank you any other
questions from members of the
committee I do have one and it has
nothing to do with this presentation it
has to do with one of your Associates
came in previously and talked about
digitizing the Supreme Court Records if
we were to find the money to do that
should we give it to the judicial branch
or to somebody else nobody else nobody
else seems to want want to take this on
as a project well I I I wish whoever
does take it on well because in my
experience it's very very difficult to
stop the Justice Bobby Hunt's Marone
train once it gets
started it really it really is not a
court project per se but an archive
project um there's history in those uh
volumes that um is invaluable and uh I
know that she wishes she were here to
speak
independently uh about that project but
uh she does not want it to detract from
the Court's capital budget request have
I answered that anywhere near satisfact
uh yes you did uh justice Hicks and it
wouldn't be at the detriment of what
you're asking it would be if we could
find money to to even start
as a separate project um we just need
somebody to be in charge of it if we do
that but we will ask the Secretary of
State in the archives on their opinion
at some point but thank that
answer great thank you other questions
from members of the
committee you have anything further
you'd like to add uh justice hick just
to thank just to thank you uh as I
whenever I get an opportunity to address
you to thank you for uh the support of
the judicial branch uh I know we're
separate branches but the Constitution
also says we do have to play well in the
sandbox together and I'm pleased that
during my tenure here at least uh I've
really treasured the relationship
between the legislative executive and
judicial branches and U we we are here
to answer any questions you can call any
one of us I think you already know where
you'll get the sophisticated answers
versus the UNS sophisticated answers uh
but don't hesitate to call us at any
time and I thank you for
appearing enjoy your
day we will thank you again thank
you the next presentation is from the
Department of Education and I see that
the commissioner is already online with
us welcome to Public Works and highways
commissioner H good morning and um I
have a relatively short capital budget
for you uh today so I can share my
screen if that's necessary but if anyone
if everyone has the information might be
easy just follow along there are two
projects um and as well I just send my
regards uh Tammy Valen Court our Chief
Financial Officer had intended to be
here but she had something that happened
this morning that required her otherwise
to not be able to join us um so she
sends her regards so the first item that
we have before you is a capital project
for a generator
um and this is over in uh our uh the
building off of Pleasant Street um this
is going to be federally funded uh the
we we do work over there for the Social
Security Administration through our SSDI
program um and the federal uh our
federal Partners in Washington have
asked that we have a generator um backup
system for the work that we're doing
over there uh they are willing to pay
for it and so we have gone to
uh Das and asked for uh them to scope
this out and so here is the proposal
that we have uh to install that
generator backup system um I can tell
you that this is a generator backup
system that would accommodate the
activities that we have which are on the
third floor of that facility uh it won't
be for the whole building I believe it
would be more if the whole building was
covered the the feds are not willing to
pay for the whole building they're
willing to pay for uh the activities
that um that we are performing for them
if the uh you know the committee
believed that it was necessary to have a
backup generator for the whole building
that would be an additional
appropriation that this committee would
need to make so that we can at least
meet Our obligation to the feds um but
that as well uh you know if you thought
it was important while we're already
doing the work on the generator to just
get a bigger one that supports the whole
building that would be a decision for
the committee to take a look at
commissioner if I may just ask a
question if we work with admin Services
about looking at doing a big one will
the federal money still be there for
inart
payment do you know it would be yep so
we would be able to proportionally
contribute to that the extent that that
would support um you know our operations
in that facility thank
you um the next project that I wanted to
bring your attention to
is um my project leadway which is really
my pre-engineering technology so these
are funds that are used every year to
procure um engineering kits and
Engineering supplies for a very specific
engineering program that we have in uh
our schools called project bead the way
um and it is a sequential uh program
that leads students through uh various
and increasing sophisticated levels of
um engineering project work it has been
very successful in the past um and is
actually a program that's quite popular
with a number of different students um
throughout the uh the educational system
so that's what this project um is used
for um commissioner again I've been here
a while this dollar amount for the pre
pre-engineering technology has stayed
relatively constant for a couple of
decades um is the 300,000 that you are
asking for sufficient to meet the needs
of our students who are involved in this
program for the coming
bium it it is and I think even in some
previous bium we have not used a full
allocation of it um but this is adequate
to support the project leadway programs
that we have and we don't anticipate um
you know they're used in many of the
schools already but we don't anticipate
that there'll be a significant increase
that we would need and we think that
this will support
that thank you for members of the
committee if you've been following along
with what the governor proposed as his
budget director mentioned when he was
here the Hudson CTE Center was funded a
year ago um in a separate bill so it
will not appear in House Bill 25 so the
commissioner will not be addressing that
particular item if I might address two
other projects I wanted I want to talk a
little bit about CTE projects in
addition um to one other project if I
may so you'll notice what is a
conspicuously absent from this budget is
a renovation for one of our CTE centers
um as you know we have a prioritized
list um of centers that uh are
refurbished on a regular basis as you
pointed out we just finished up the
funding for the Hudson uh CTE Center um
the next projects that are in the queue
have been uh Whitefield uh is one of the
projects um Whitefield has had several
um attempts locally to get their local
funding for this um I think they've had
two or three attempts at that uh they
have another one that they have put
together that they're going to be
bringing forward uh to their local
voters um it is a project again because
it's been in the works for a while that
they believe that they have scoped the
project such that they can get local
community support um but they don't have
that in this bium and therefore you
don't see it in this particular uh
budget request to you uh the other is
Claremont who ordinarily would have been
scheduled to be able to be refurbished
dur as well during this period of time
um and Claremont as well deferred the
process um with the intention of
combining with Newport which is one of
the next projects that is up in the
queue um and to do a combined
opportunity there um potentially a
combined Center maybe even coordinating
with the community college system um and
through those collaborations we actually
achieved some efficiencies in that
process um but again that project is not
ready to bring before you because it has
not yet finished the planning process
nor the local um approval process so
that is continuing to move forward um we
do do have coming up behind them we've
got projects in uh Milford and in
Peterboro and we continue to um you know
talk to them they are in their planning
stage they um I believe they've even in
Milford anyways they've begun
architectural work um so we think that
those will come to you in schedule um
but the other thing to keep in mind as a
committee is that uh the way that we
have prioritized these refurbishments is
initially you know going back I believe
as far as like back in
1974 uh we started the buildout of our
CTE centers across the state and then
when we got to the refurbishment process
we just went back to the beginning of
the list and have been working our way
through the list which has kind pretty
much have followed that list there have
been some you know movement depending
upon the Readiness of the community to
be able to uh engage that work um but we
are approaching the end of the list
again and our working very closely with
the legislative committee the S sp190
committee uh to really decide if that's
the appropriate approach to decide which
CP Center we build next or we work on
next and do we really want to tackle
complete refurbishments or should we
have a more incremental approach where
we're refurbishing various programs as
those programs need refurbishment as the
technology changes as new opportunities
develop um so that should probably be
coming before the legislature uh if not
this session maybe in the next session
as well to relook at how we decide which
priority which projects we really want
to prioritize through that effort um and
then there is one other project that I
want to just bring to your attention
that will come to you through the
department of administrative Services uh
this has now come before the committee
uh you know several times I think this
is might be the third time and I'm
hoping that the third time is a charm
we'll see um it's not in my budget
because it deals with the facility that
I have here at the Department of
Education and it is a refurbishment of
the restroom facilities um at the
department uh the Department of
Education pre pandemic and hopefully in
the near future um has quite a number of
unique outside visitors uh we receive
about 7,000 unique outside visitors per
year um and because we run all kinds of
uh you know boards associated with the
education system we run a number of
different student programming that
students may have meetings or something
in this building lots of educator
preparation activities that go on we
also do the relicensing here in the
department so again 7,000 unique
visitors per year come through here um
the the actual facilities um are
particularly uh they may even be
considered embarrassing a little bit um
I've never been in the ladies room but I
understand that it is um potentially not
even safe because of unevenness of floor
um and so this is funding to refurbish
those uh so that we we're not looking
for um you know extravagance but
professionalism in terms of all of those
unique impressions that we're making on
a on a regular basis each year so we
just wanted to highlight that project
for you as well and and that is the
extent of our capital budget this year
um commissioner I remember the
discussions previously about the
restrooms at your your building from
prior capital budget it's I do not see
it in admin Services
requests um this year if you and
commissioner Arling house could get
together before the 10th of March and
provide us with something that says what
the scope and cost of this would be
because I'm sure if I go back to last
capital budget discussions those figures
are no longer correct the comme will at
least look at it no guarantees that
we'll we'll be able to fund it but at
least now that you have raised the issue
we should have a cost factor involved
and what the scope of the work is if if
you and and your counterpart at admin
Services could do that I would
appreciate and I think most of the
committee would as well rather than just
throwing a dollar am in there yep I'm
happy to do that I believe we have a
scoped amount but I'll confirm that the
number I'm looking at on the the
document I was provided is is is up to
date and accurate so thank you any other
questions for the
commissioner representative
Eble thank you
um I I apologize I'm just I'm sort of
confused because the governor's budget
is different than what you've got in
your book and we don't have a
presentation and maybe I'm not thinking
quite clearly after the last two days
but so I just want to clarify your like
I want to get the total amount of your
requests so the first thing is the
generator which is 260 which doesn't hit
the bottom line because it's fed funds
there's the pre-engineering technology
Hudson we always to already took care
of what so that so what's next so that's
all in other words let me I didn't I can
share the presentation with you I'm
sorry I um yeah we didn't have that you
had some of that the slides with you so
the only two projects that I have before
you are this is the first one which is
really the generator install over in my
Walker building that's
$250,000 and that is federally funded
and then the other one that I have is my
pre-engineering technology which is the
$300,000 okay all right and then the
bathrooms and having visited the uh
ladies room I can testify to the fact
that they really should be upgraded yes
okay so here was the this is the
estimate that I have on the bathroom
that we I believed was in the das's
budget but I will connect with
commissioner Arley house and make sure
that it's there but I believe that this
is the updated estimate for that
work thank
you and commissioner if you could just
mention what was I assume one of your
number one priorities this the
information
system that did not make it into the
capital
so it did not make it because it didn't
need to so what I did is again this is
another one of those projects that I
believe for this is my third go round at
it and uh but we were able to um obtain
a um a grant from the federal government
to allow us to move that project forward
and therefore I didn't need to include
it into my capital budget and that's why
um and again this is some of the timing
so when I was doing my budget you know
before the governor's phase I didn't
have a grant you know and then I got a
grant so then the governor didn't need
to put it into his budget because I've
already found another mechanism to take
care of it is really what's that's the
reason why you don't see that carry
forward thank you but it always raises a
question when we see you know at
agency's number one priority not being
even considered or talked about at all I
went out and found somebody else to
pay thank
uh representative Abbot yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you commissioner for
taking my question I just wondered if is
sort of a followup to the Chairman's uh
question um is this in any
way relative
to House Bill 194 which we voted on
yesterday which was
approved by margin if I have it
correctly
194 to
162 so can you just refresh my
memory student assessment information
and
data yeah so it is not directly
connected to that um it would help with
that but it is not directly connected
this is the student information system
is really a an an upgrade in terms of
our technology across the
that would really just improve uh the
efficiency of our ability to um you know
report gather and Report information we
will probably save man years of time at
the local school district uh they're
spending quite a bit of time and then
they transmit information to the
department we spend quite a bit of time
um it will improve our ability to be
responsive to the legislature in terms
of information that they might need and
truthfully it will improve the
uh the data security around our student
information as well okay thank
you and commissioner members of the
committee um on the consent calendar
that we approved yesterday there is a
study committee um to look at
CTE um
education and the rest it has seven
members of the House assuming that it
becomes law and I did ask that um the
chair of Education make a note that at
least one member of Public Works should
be on that study committee because we do
fund what is happening in it so just be
aware that one of you may get
tapped but it it is I think what
commissioner is alluding to about
studying the way we go about uh
prioritizing and looking at the
technology and educational component of
the CTE from from a legislative point of
view any other questions of the
commissioner represent yes speaking of
CTE I'm wondering you commissioner you
talked about the White Field do you know
if the White Field School District is
going to vote next month on a proposal
to for that so that if they approved it
for some reason would could we consider
in this year's capital budget are you
aware of that commissioner I don't know
so I do actually you know Eric prow
worth is on the line if somebody wants
to bring him up he may know specifically
more information um so Eric frow worth
is our CTE director in the state and I
know he was jumping into the call so if
somebody can promote him to VA a host um
so I do believe that they have an
application that they will be bringing
to their voters um but I don't know if
it's the type of thing that you know the
the runway or the ramp is such that we
would then be able to get it in it would
make sense to have it in this budget or
we would stick it into the next budget
and I don't know if Eric if you want to
comment on
that uh sure good morning thank you um
so yes uh I'm not sure if Whitefield is
going to their March vote I can
certainly find out from uh our director
Rob Scott uh they attempted last year
and I believe they missed the vote by
four or five votes uh so it was very
close uh so I believe they were working
with their architect to see where they
could
uh pair down or pair back some of their
proposals uh to bring the budget line at
them down a little bit further uh as as
you're aware the the town the locals are
responsible for 25% of the
construction and uh so that's what that
had been put on their March uh last year
um if it did get
approved this March I believe it is
still I I don't believe they would be
able to start this summer they might be
able to start next summer they're
typically um you know an 18-month
process so uh we're we're looking at for
example Claremont uh and Newport uh for
next
year uh January of next year they would
bring their proposal to us uh for them
to be able to start the following summer
so it is it's a fairly long process uh
once they get the green light um but we
can certainly ask uh Whitefield uh if
they would could be available to start
in uh 23 instead of waiting to
24 okay thank you yeah if you could
please provide that any in updated
information to this committee on that
issue but I also have another question
Mr chairman um so assuming and
Whitefield for some reason approves it
and you you put to put it in it sounds
like you wouldn't put it in till the
next biennium but my understanding is on
assuming Newport and Claremont voters
approve their share would you still have
include their CTE in the next
bium for consider be correct yeah we
would have basically two projects coming
at you in that next finum budget which
is really not un un that's kind of the
norm is that we normally would have two
that are ready to go okay all right but
commissioner if I could Echo what
representative cluder just said if
Whitefield were to have something on the
ballot this March and it is approved I
think that it is incumbent upon this
committee to at least look at coming up
with a portion or all of the state shair
so that they can begin in 23 rather than
waiting on the hope that the next
legislature will do something um and
having a vote res sended at the top
level or something I I just worry about
that and make sure that we have our
chair with them at when when they begin
to do the planning and other process
yeah we can absolutely follow up with
them I do know that the you know when we
were putting our budget together at that
time they were not prepared in this mium
to be able to go forward but we'll
confirm that uh if they want to try and
accelerate some of that that they're
going to be able to make that happen and
I believe town meeting day is the 9th of
March so we should know by that yeah
we'll give him a call today thank you
yeah thank you very much and thank you
Mr chairman any any other questions of
the commissioner or his staff
representative
eil going back to my favorite question
about the bathrooms I just want to make
sure we get um information on your
requests to uh include in our
review we will make sure that you have
that thank
you well no no
no any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much commissioner I appreciate you and
your staff being here and as always um
we shall see what we can find for you
great thank you so much yes I do know
that it's a difficult
task members of the committee the next
presentation is not scheduled to start
for five minutes at
10:45 remember that the likes are live
um so take a minute if you have to get a
cup of coffee for those that are at home
uh can I we get an update for anybody
that was the attendance okay um if any
of the members who are participating
remotely did not answer the roll call
when the clerk um said that if they
could raise their hand now um so that we
know who has been participating in the
committee I would appreciate
it this is representative kolansky and I
do not know how to raise my hand but I
did log in late and did not make the
original thank
you not
sure yeah you
did I don't
think oh we see you uh
Mike represent
okay thank you all it just uh much
harder to do this um then if you're
sitting around the
room
[Music]
um oh you got it raised representative
kazinski thank
you was that kalansky or kazinski
kalansky okay said oh he's here too
somewhere
okay he's not on right
now thought the clerk said he wouldn't
have an issue between those two I
know I
don't what he try to say
back
so when are we starting again 10:45 1045
there are fewer additional requests than
what's in the
right see eight or 10 and being narrowed
down to four yeah I don't know what
Guidance the government gave to
people just did a lot more calling
before it came to us well yeah
but he may have told well yeah because
that's went
to and that
Comm hard I think everyone yeah
I it would appear to me that they were
given a
harder and and the fact that while they
were preparing the things the governor
put all capital projects on because we
didn't
know going to
happen so you we'll see sure that
there'll be others like U education you
know well this one
pro just like that one that was2 and
half million just got off the table like
well really how did
that they're making great strides in the
portable bathrooms too I just wanted to
put in the
hallway it's funny how that seems to be
a big concern the
bathrooms I know it was a big
concern when we renovate one of the
ladies rooms in
St concern at the prison no that's we
have
to those mules
and and everything else they
C my wife came out of a restroom
somewhere we were one time and she said
there's a couch and two really nice
overstuffed chairs in there and I go
I've never been in a men's room that has
a couch
[Music]
okay I'd like to call the committee back
to order at this point
it our next presentation is from the
depart uh The Fish and Game Commission
and I see that director is up um welcome
to Public Works and highways uh director
Mason um I see you only have one project
listed uh thank you very much chairman
uh Graham uh yeah this is we only have
one project but for fishing game this is
a rather large project um today I have
with me uh our immediate past chief of
Inland Fisheries Jason Smith and Jason
has been working on this project for
several years so I've asked him to
present today I think he he has a more
detailed on background knowledge on this
project than I do Jason fine whomever
you wanted to to present in the best
possible
bner okay uh thank you representative as
director Mason said my name is Jason
Smith and I've been intimately involved
in this project my former role here with
fishing
games so all of our hatcheries operate
under an EPA permit called the NP permit
I'm sure most of you are familiar with
until this most recent permit that went
into effect on January 1st we never had
any numerical values for any nutrients
any quantitative limits in our permit
our new permit that's been issued by EPA
now has numerical values for phosphorus
in it so in order to for our facility to
maintain compliance with our nepes
permit issued by EPA we need to build
some sort of wastewater treatment
facility uh to remove nutrients in order
to maintain operation of the facility
Powder Mill hatchery in new durm is our
largest uh state-owned and operated Fish
Hatchery it provides fish to about third
of the state these are uh brook trout
rainbow
trout and brown trout for recreational
angling and historically we've also
raised every landlock salmon that's
stocked into our large
lakes out of this particular facility so
it's a very critical to uh fishing games
Mission here to provide these
opportunities and and that's why we're
trying to move forward we're making
these significant investments in order
to continue to
[Music]
operate uh question yeah um question
from the committee representative mononi
thank you um thank you commissioner and
and serve for taking the question could
you just run run through this so in the
past are you saying that we had uh the
availability to
discharge from your um I don't know what
the right term for your
Aqua growing directly out into another
water source and now we can't do that
any longer you need to process it remove
remove these materials is that what
you're telling me that is fundamentally
correct yes
[Music]
okay any other representative
EO thank you um thank you for being here
today so this is a pretty big
expenditure is there any way to split it
up
over a longer period of years or is it
um sort of an All or Nothing thing and
maybe you could just describe a little
more what it
entails so our initial draft EPA permit
included a five-year compliance schedule
in
it and it was kind of model after the
state revolving funds over a Dees for
their Wastewater program so this is
already a fairly long um drawn out
process and it will have significant
timelines but part of this process we
still have to go into preliminary design
and engineering and then and get you
know a hard number for a cost estimate
and then from there we'll have you know
a scope of services to put out the bid
so this will be a kind of a extended
long-term um project and we won't be
spending all the funds all all up front
and I hope that answers your
question um yeah I I mean some I don't
know any sometimes what we do is we
authorize the expend the uh expenditure
of the funding for the engineering and
the preliminary scoping and then we sort
of split it up a little bit so um I
don't know if there's a number you could
give us for that for just discussion
purposes and yes there is and I believe
director Mason provided you with an
updated report from an engineering firm
called ganet Fleming and in part of that
report uh there's about
$515,000 in that report if I recall
correctly that is for design and study
um that would probably be about a you
know two-year evaluation so there would
be a window there um and an Al
alternative method to get the way we
need to
be
um Mr
Shay thank you represent Graham I just
wanted to confirm what the fish and game
department that the funding for this
project is Fish and Game funds correct
oh not General
funds that would be correct yeah so I
just wanted the committee to hear that
um and and I did have a question along
the same lines um director this will be
a big chunk of fishing game funds
repaying this fond can the fund absorb
that payment as well always keep up with
your normal operating costs um over the
course of the the bond and any others
that we issue in the future for these
same
problems um at this time yes um this
particular banian budget we have a very
low um request going into the general
fund um but I don't see that you know I
I'm hoping as we move forward in the
future that that that funding level will
go up back to more historical levels
than where we are right now um and if
that takes place and if we don't you
know if we're not having any I guess if
I don't any unforeseen issues that would
create larger Capital um um demands on
the agency we should be okay thank you
representative
bunker hi director thank you for taking
my call could you remind me please what
are the revenue sources of the fish and
game
fund um license
sales
um do we operate operate under uh us
fish and wildlife sport fish restoration
as well for uh for our federal
aid thank
you any other question
for the director or his staff if I could
one more um represent
mononi thank you director um so um this
facility uh the Powder Mill is is your
largest of your hatcheries is the EPA uh
it's a couple three parts Mr chairman
EPA requiring because of the volume of
this facility that you need to do this
and are you going to have to do similar
at your other projects for them that are
smaller in the
future so this is Jason again um just to
back up a little bit we're one of the
few states that is still act operating
our hatcheries without any type of
numerical values for
nutrients um we knew this was coming
eventually but what's kind of
accelerated this particular
project is the uh the receiving water in
which
Hatchery discharges his effluent has
become an impaired water body okay so
there's been a lot of pressure and put
on EPA to make sure that what we if we
continue to operate that we are going to
not have any additional negative impacts
of the downstream
environment and as far as the other
hatcheries goes
um our four of our other five hatcheries
are currently going to be put under
what's called the general
permit and those General permits that I
saw in draft form did still did not have
any numerical values for
nutrients thank thank you for that so it
would also knowing that in the future
that something like that may become um a
regulation you need to follow it seemed
to me when you're going through your
your initial engineering that you'll
you'll have a a base map for anything
else smaller going forward so um would
that would that be
true that is true um but some of the
figures that we provided you we were
kind of under some significant time
constraints when we put this capital
budget together and several things that
we did not have the ability to
do when we put this request is due to
covid we weren't able to have a site
visit with the engineers who updated the
uh an older report for the cost and at
that time we still did not have the
numerical values that actually came out
in our final permit so you'll see
there's a couple versions of this uh
document to support what we're asking
for and the most recent one is the one
that was conducted after we saw what the
numerical values in our permit were and
after they had an opportunity to to see
the site and you know many of you might
not be aware of how our facilities
operate but this particular hat was
built in the 1940s and when they came to
do the site visit you know there was
some other infrastructure that probably
will need to be addressed in order to
retrofit the system that we need to put
in so that kind of added to the cost uh
from the initial proposal as well thank
you sh R
Newman yes director I'm I'm I'm just a
little confused I'm going back to the um
to the 4 million6 that you're that
you're looking for did I hear you
earlier say but you haven't gone out to
bid yet so this is a best guesstimate as
to what is anticipated to be an
expense yeah it's an Engineers estimate
on what the expense will be um it in
January it was revised to
5.1 okay could this go higher or Could
It Go
lower this is Jas I think I think you
know I think we have a good Target as
far as what the costs are going to be
but we really won't have a hard hard
figure and a hard value until we really
roll the sleeves up and get on site and
start doing the
[Music]
design so I'm I'm looking at a map so am
I do I does the marry Mac River flow
into the mar I mean maraming River flow
into the maraming lake that the water
body or what's marry meeting lake is the
water source for this Hatchery gotcha
and at the end of the Hatchery and the
Overflow of the lake forms a Mary
meeting river which flows through about
11 miles of wetlands through several
empowerments before it reaches Alton
Bay win a sorry follow up yeah
any further questions of the director
and his
staff Mr
Shay sorry repr G I just want to confirm
with the Department what is the amount
that they need in their capital budget
the governor's proposed capital budget
is $4
m615 th000 you've mentioned an amount of
5.1
million so I just wanted to clarify
before you leave today what so the
committee can hear what your request
is
so like I said this capital budget
proposal was put together uh with the
updated cost estimate of 4.3 there was
another 300,000 that was added to that
because as you probably know that we
have to contract through Bureau Public
Works to oversee these projects so that
I think that additional 300,000 was
there cost but but since we've been on
site um there were some additional costs
that weren't available at the time so uh
I hate to modify a request this late in
the game but you know we're hoping we
can do it for the 4.6 but in reality
after being on site it may be uh more
towards the five million
Mark if to follow up on that um I would
hate to give you 4.6 and come to find
out that you got to wait two years to do
anything because you don't have enough
money
um so we need a hard figure to put in
this understanding that it all will be
um fishing game
funds understood understood but as I
mentioned earlier there'll be a couple
years of design so I don't know if there
would be if obviously I understand your
approach and it's really hard to go back
for additional funds but um we may know
we we may know
more uh the next capital budget cycle
and be able to provide the committee
more specific number I I think what I'm
getting at is you know there a couple
different ways to go about this and I
think ultimately it's up to the
committee and and the director my
perspective we're not going to up the
dollar amount that is in the the
governor's capital budget proposal that
is up to the committee but that's my
perspective
okay representative
Newman thank you before we move on to
the next presentation
yes thank you director um what's the
current cost of a fishing license and
how many are sold annually like how many
were sold last
year so this is Jason again um represent
I'm sorry Jason our uh fishing license
fees are about $45 for a resident
fishing license uh non-residents are
slightly
higher and this is an odd year because
we had due to everyone being outside and
wanting to go fishing we had a kind of a
record license sale but historically we
sell about 140 150,000 licenses per
year okay and and if I could just follow
up yeah has that um has the fee the
resident fee
increased or when was the last time it
was increased we went through a license
fee increase back in 2015
okay thank
you seeing no further questions uh
director Jason thank you very much for
for being here
um and we shall work on the capital
budget thank
you we'll go right into the next
presentation from um The Liquor
Commission and I see that
um the chairman is with
us yes good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Joseph M I'm the chairman of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission and with
me is our CFO Tina deir we're happy to
be in front of you this morning and Tina
will take you through our capital budget
reviews thank you good morning and for
the record as stated I am Tina deur I'm
the CFO for the Liquor Commission we
only have one new capital project in
front of you today and is for a million
dollars to add to our current nextg
project the original request was um
included for supplemental funding for
the project at that time we didn't know
if we would need the money but since
then it has been determined that we need
the funding to add additional moraki
access points to get Wi-Fi in our stores
that's
250,000 400 ,000 for wirer scanners to
support our inventory so that the um the
retail store clerks and employees can
scan the inventory and we need 50,000 to
replace the office printers with
scanners to um coordinate with the new
POS system that we're putting in place
we know that this time was to present
New Capital request however because this
request relates to a current project we
thought it would be uh prudent to bring
in front of you our lap State extensions
and if you would like we can go through
those
now go
ahead so on page 3 to six you'll see the
nextg project it we provided you the
original request the background and the
current status of the project um because
you have it in front of you and had time
to review it we won't go through all of
the pages but we would be happy to
answer any questions that you have on
the pro
project okay if there are none then on
page s to8 the next um lap State
Extension we're asking for is for our
Hampton Stores um again we've provided
you all of the information on the
background and where the project is
today and we would be happy to answer
any questions you have on that project
if if we could hold off on the lasts
extensions there will be a separate U
meeting of uh um
subcommittee of the the U the committee
to to look at all of the extensions to
which you will be invited um okay course
um and I just want to make one note that
all of the uh debt that's associated
with the projects are liquor funded we
have them in our
budget so if I look at it from what you
said
earlier um all you're asking for this
year is in a capital appropriation is
the $1 million that is correct correct
that's less that we I've ever seen from
you
guys well with revenues being up 5.3% or
26.7 million uh I think we appreciate
that that I know our representative
abbit question yes thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for taking my question I
just um would ask the standard question
has this um request been run through the
IT
department yes we're working closely
with doit and Das on this project thank
you any other
questions um representative eil
um as long as you're here I wondered if
you could share any comments or thoughts
on the recent audit
report all I can say representative is
that we're always uh grateful for any
type of uh audit that we get at the
commission because we feel that it makes
us a better business and we're working
forward uh we have uh uh the meeting set
in March and we're very confident that
the committee will be very happy with
the progress that the commission makes
in that period of time we don't look at
this as uh anything negative uh
unfortunately uh audits happen and they
they they they look at a certain segment
of time and the commission has grown
well beyond that uh since that period of
time and I think that uh the business
running the way it is and as profitable
as it has been uh there's going to be
growing pains as you go through those
types of things and like anything else
that has been brought before us in the
last 10 years we will uh overcome that
and we'll make sure that we're where we
need to
be as far as compliance is
concerned any further
questions I to wrap up um
representative mononi uh thank you um
and my question would be a little easier
so um we we saw Revenue numbers
projected and uh they're favorable
through uh this last year with covid and
so forth for whatever reasons when are
you going to bring back our two times a
year discount for liquor
sales you me they have no control over
it and I was hoping to discuss it with
you today
well representative thank you for the
question uh obviously the Liquor
Commission is uh statuto obligated to uh
make make a profit and be as profitable
as we can be and through our research uh
we have found that those types of sales
do they drive sales but they do not
drive net profit so what we found in
going with a monthly sale a category
sale like you're seeing a do now uh with
a 15 or 20% discount uh tends to be more
profitable for the commission and thus
more profitable for the general fund so
I do not think unfortunately for the
question that you've raised that you'll
see those types of sales come back in
the near future we're
crushed are crushed all right Christmas
thank you
though um any other qu pertinent
questions about the capital projects of
um The Liquor
Commission seeing none thank you
chairman um and your staff we appreciate
you coming
forward um
so we will work to finalize the capital
budget thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee your time is
greatly appreciated thank you thank you
okay while I have I will send this out
to the members of the committee um as
you looked at
um last uh the calendar that came out
last night
hopefully some of you have looked at it
we will be meeting on the 5th of March
to hear more
presentations that will be completely
remote there will not be anybody in the
committee
room on the 10th of March we will finish
up uh committee presentations completely
remotely that will appear in a future
calendar and begin to look at um some of
what we want to do with the capital
budget in a full committee work session
on that same day um on the 12th of March
uh representative Jack will be chairing
the laps extension work session um I
have asked Mr Shay to send that link out
for that to all members even if you
didn't sign up to be on it if you want
to chime in and
participate um with that is that also G
be completely remote it's completely
remote the following two weeks are up in
the air because I do not know how many
session days there will be after the
number of bills that we kick um
yesterday to the next session we have a
hard deadline of the 18th of March I
know that the speaker is working hard on
trying to determine how many days that
week we will
meet um but I don't have an answer to
that at this point um that will impact
on when committees can meet because the
very next
week is the hard deadline for all bills
that went to a second committee this
this past uh Wednesday so I'm trying to
work out when we can have the formal
public hearing
on um House Bill 25 which I signed off
on yesterday you will be getting a hard
copy I believe Mr Shay um of that um
sometime in the near future um it
essentially mirrors what was in the go
Governor's Proposal with a couple of
changes um
I am still trying to figure out in
conjunction with the speaker in his
office whether or not that public
hearing and any subsequent work sessions
and executive sessions can be held
completely remote or not um as you can
imagine um with 20 committees trying to
finish their work in a very short couple
of three weeks um room space um due to
covid is very tight
I will hopefully know by Monday anything
for those following two weeks
um um after the the 12th of March on
where we're going and what we have um I
will keep the committee informed and for
the public who is listening all of that
will also appear obviously in the the
calendar and with that I didn't quite
time this all out um our next
presentation is not until 1:00 as it
says in the calendar does any member of
the committee have a comment or question
at this
point seeing none we are in recess until
1 pm and we have two committees to hear
from one of which was alluded to um by
fishing Gabe Dees and the other one
Department of Corrections did Mr Shay
has his hand
up or had it
up I I'm sorry represent Graham I just
was I didn't know if you were gonna say
anything more um I just wanted to
confirm yes um I'll work with Brad and
and a hard copy of House Bill 25 will be
provided to the committee along with um
for those members that have been on the
committee in the past the the compare
sheet that we fill out so there'll be a
um a list of all the projects that are
in the House Bill 25 and then what the
governor's recommended amount is and
then um there'll be empty space for the
house to fill in their ideas or what
they want to do and I will also send out
a um lapse extension worksheet as well
so everybody will get all that because
I'm not sure who will end up
participating at the laps extension
meetings but um so so I just want to let
the committee know that that that you
will get some paper from me in the next
uh few days anyways you probably be
about a week before you actually see it
by the time the mail gets to you but
once House Bill 25 is available to make
copies of and um create those um those
documents I just described to you we'll
get them copied and in the mail to you
so I hope hopefully by Monday and Mr
Shay you will also be sending those uh
work sheet compare sheets out
electronically I believe oh absolutely
everything will go out electronically as
well um and and will be found on our
website so that if if you don't get the
mail in time it will be available um to
at least have it electronically when I
send it to you I'll send it to you in
Excel so that you can um you know thank
you adust it with calculations that you
might want to put in
there I will also put it in a PDF file
too for those members that find it
easier to print a PDF
file you do good work Mr
Shay I'm
trying all right the committee will
stand in recess until 100 p.m. um sorry
about the long break um but it happen as
I'm sure the former chairs here will
testify absolutely thank you all never
this
longor
e
e e
many of them told me that they were
disappointed
e
e e
I'd like to call the public works and
highways committee back to order um this
afternoon we'll continue with hearing
presentations by various State agents
sees the next one up is the Department
of Environmental
Services who do we
have Robert Scott on Mr Scott
welcome well welcome thank you thank you
for having us uh M Mr chair I didn't see
who was speaking I assume it's the chair
uh and and thank you so uh I I want to
draw your attention to we do have a
PowerPoint that was provided to you uh
if the committee would desire we could
try to get it up on the screen or
or first that be my first question would
you like it on the screen or I can just
talk to it um a variety of the members
um because it came in while we were in
the last two days of session have not
had the opportunity to look at it so if
uh you could bring it up and whomever
else on your staff needs to chime in
have them just identify themselves so we
know who it is before they start okay we
will do that so I don't know if Chris
you can do that or I know Sue Carlson's
uh are waiting to do that if if uh
that's an issue but while commissioner I
can bring it up if you would like or if
Sue would like me to bring it
up go ahead
Chris just one second so while we're
while we're bringing that up uh I'll
introduce uh some of my key staff that
are on uh Sue Carlson is our chief
opting officer and I suppose I should
start I guess you introduce me anyways
I'm Bob Scott I'm the commissioner for
Department of Environmental Services uh
so sue Carlson is our chief operating
officer uh we also have on uh is uh tom
o Donovan who is the director of our
Water Division uh Mike whimet who is the
director of our Waste Management
Division and Craig Wright who is the
director of our air Resources Division
uh we also have some key staff available
uh who are are on uh in particular Jim
Gallagher who's the head of our dam
Bureau uh he's I jokingly call him our
dam engineer so um that's as funny as I
get so uh so with that and now we're on
the screen thank you Chris uh again I'll
run through our slides and obviously uh
we're happy to answer any and all of
your questions so uh going to the next
slide thank you so what you see here is
our summary of our uh 2223 capital
budget requests uh We've we we're
showing you what we asked for and what
what uh is pres is presented in the
budget but Governor's request to
you uh as the table shows we've gotten a
little bit less than we asked for we
have a a small reductions in the state
revolving loan matching funds for both
clean water and drinking water uh and
removal of uh an item for our water
quality our Coastal flood item that you
see there number six uh we're not asking
for any increases beyond what the
governor has requested uh and we'll be
able to in the following slides we'll
detail uh the five uh items that are
being requested through the budget
Governor's budget excuse me so uh Chris
if you can go to the next one thank
you so as you I'm sure you're aware uh
one of the uh uh large items typically
in the capital budget and one of our UH
responsibilities is uh maintenance of uh
dams in the State uh state owned dams uh
we have uh in this case we have uh an
$8.1 million request uh to do several uh
major components to that type of work uh
so so on eight dams is repair and
reconstruction work uh we have
engineering and design uh work that
needs to be done on on several dams and
preparation for the final actual Spade
work so to speak uh hydrological work on
three dams and uh very importantly uh an
asset management plan work to be done as
we do which I'll talk about in a moment
uh uh to assess uh where we are for for
our our
dams um so with that uh we'll move Chris
is already moving me ahead that's good
thank you for that
uh so uh running through these just to
give you an idea of the the the Dan that
we're talking about uh the wi uh
River Watershed uh needs hydrologic and
hydraulic
evaluations uh and uh as part of their
uh new emergency action plans uh for the
dam which is a requ federal requirement
uh and uh again the the typical work
we're doing uh involves
dams that have a relatively high impact
to Downstream so high Hazard dams that
that type of activity again we can talk
to that also uh as you see here we have
work work for mendums
pond uh and py Way Lake dams Mar meeting
River dams which are three uh fish and
game owned dams surrounding Mery meeting
Lake uh and they all need a feasibility
uh study to determine the cost and
effort needed to bring excuse me bring
them into safety uh compliance with
safety requirements uh the last issue uh
item here and it's not by priority by
any means is an asset management plan so
one thing I do want to alert the
legislators uh on the on the the call
here is uh the the obviously we spent a
lot of time
assessing uh the condition of our dams
to figure out what work needs to be done
and making sure they're safe for obvious
reasons uh it's important for us to be
able to
to uh spend a little bit more time to
get uh an asset management plan in place
and work done on that end so uh of the
274 state owned dams we don't even
though we have looked at them we don't
have a complete comprehensive management
plan for all the dams and that includes
an assessment of their condition so uh I
guess what I what I want to as a
takeaway for you all not in this budget
uh but the the bad news is the more we
look at the condition of our dams uh on
on average they're you know we're
talking over 100 years for many of these
dams uh we're finding more and more work
needs to be done uh this Asset
Management plan uh and that work will
help us quantify that a little bit
better uh so I I I don't have a great uh
story saying the costs are going to go
down but it it's it's critical work and
obviously we need have need to have a
great handle a better handle uh on what
that will mean mean uh moving forward
board so uh that's what that Asset
Management plan light item is by the way
so uh if we go to the next slide Chris
thank you I do have one question on that
last slide yes sir the Mary meeting
River dams we heard this morning from uh
fishing game about their um Hatchery
that feeds either feeds off of that or
feeds into it I forget which way it went
is this being planned in conjunction
with the work that they are undertaking
to
control um the the phosphorus that's
coming out of their
Hatchery it's not directly related so as
you're aware the the Potter Mill
Hatchery uh you know again at the design
at the time made a lot of sense but
unfortunately it takes up almost 100% of
the water body as it flows through the
hatry uh and and the the U the impact of
the fish are are having an impact in a
federal federal EPA permitting issue
that that's going on with that so no so
short answer is no these aren't directly
related uh not to be flipping about it
but I guess if the dams were to let go
that would wash away the problem but I
don't think anybody wants that but
they're not they're not directly
related okay thank
you having said that we're we're we're
very involved with fishing game and and
trying to help them on that that that
issue by the way so uh that's important
to us too in the state as you know so
the next slide is our our One Stop is
the name we've given our
Collective collection of uh databases so
we have a lot of regulatory programs a
lot of uh environmental results programs
you know what's your water quality that
type of thing uh in the agency so over
20 years uh out of hid so to speak we've
kind of clued together uh electronic
means to access these type of systems
including to some extent
permitting uh that is a really you know
was it was necessary and it's important
to many people including us the
regulated Community uh uh and just the
general citizenry it's very outdated and
probably you got my uh tone by saying
they were Clues together so uh what
we're finding is that's not real
sustainable right right now so what as
an example
uh over a year a little over a year ago
uh we had uh doit did a had one of their
contractors was looking at the system
found that even the coding for some of
these databases created cyber security
issues which which could easily
compromise all the data in the systems
uh so we had to we were forced to pull
that that system down that collect
collection of systems down so the I
guess the good news to that was uh it
did have the impact of clearly
demonstrating how important this is to
everybody so we we instantly got calls
from many many people uh expressing
concerns about it and when can we get it
back up so uh you know again there
there's always a silver lining I suppose
but that really uh helped reinforce with
us how important this this work is so
with that uh we we uh have a line item
here to to help work on that it's really
critical in my mind uh in order to to
keep us as customer service friendly as
possible and as effective as possible
too as you may imagine uh you know again
good news bad news once we get to a
point where people are are working on
their applications for permits uh or
licensing that type of thing online uh
that there's rightly so an expectation
that we we keep doing those type of
things and we we totally agree but you
know as as you I'm sure you're aware
that that takes
um uh resources uh the last item on this
um the last bullet on this slide is our
air monitoring stations so we are also
uh I I mentioned uh environmental data
uh we monitor air pollution uh levels uh
which thankfully have gotten better and
better by the way uh in the State uh
throughout the state and uh that is
intended to be an automated system uh we
actually have during certain times of
the year when we have air quality issues
uh we have have systems so that can be
viewed by the public so they can make
judgment calls for instance do I go
hiking today that type of thing and we
have statutory requirements from the
feds uh the EPA uh of getting that data
to the federal system also uh so this
would help with up upgrading that the
the station equipment generally is over
10 years old that we're all of it that
we're talking about uh and and it's hard
hard to find replacement parts and uh it
it's failing in in different aspects so
that's the other part of that uh last
bullet there so Chris if we can go to
the next
slide so uh this part of the B budget
request is for the state match for both
clean water and drinking water State
revolving loan funds uh most of you are
probably aware of that uh drinking water
obviously is is self uh explanatory
clean water for those who aren't
initiated with that I think uh
Wastewater and Sewer uh type things so
that's it's to get the water cleaner uh
but uh right now the state's required uh
to do a 20% match uh the good news is
uh both for clean water and for drinking
water uh it's it's really a force
multiplier uh in in order to to get
federal funds in so uh again as the last
bullet shows uh uh that those funds will
provide mats for $60 million in federal
funds which uh by and large go to the
municipalities uh again uh it's a low
interest interest Loan program with the
potential for loan
forgiveness uh and it really enables a
lot of municipalities to do the work
that they need to do uh for this
citizens so it's uh again the good news
bad news story as always is uh these
programs are over subscribed uh uh and
and we hear hearing inklings uh that
there may be depending on what happens
in Congress more funds coming in but we
we're we've had nothing to verify that
yet so that's uh not before us at the
moment so uh Chris uh the final
slide so the wabaki River Basin program
so that's uh for those who aren't
familiar with that that is a regional uh
waste R treatment facility that is owned
and operated by the state of New
Hampshire we we have staff there and uh
operators there it it uh is funded
through 10 communities uh uh ranging
from Meredith to Franklin uh and that so
that is not a general fund request for
capital budget monies uh but it is uh
certainly uh funded by those municip
those participating municipalities uh
entities uh and much similar to most
facilities uh the certain parts of the
facility are over 40 years old and need
replacing uh there there's a board that
um helps guide the agency uh in uh uh
making decisions on the the future of
the plant and and how it's operated in
in Investments uh that Advisory Board uh
fully supports uh these these
requests um and uh again it will be
funded through uh talked about clean
water srf State revolving loans uh and
paid back through uh the assessments of
the communities again so this will be uh
funded FR for the uh users in this case
so with that uh and again uh we're just
trying to give you a brief overview uh
we're happy to answer questions uh again
I have some key staff here also uh if we
end up uh if if you are get beyond my
ability or Sue which uh you you you
could easily get beyond my ability to
answer questions perhaps but I'm going
to guess probably not Sue Carlson's but
in either case uh we have staff here
available for you
all thank you H representative Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
all from here people have had trouble
with
that first of all I was delighted to
hear you use the word clu uh secondly
going back to the onetop system are you
coordinating with doic so that you're
harmonizing your development with uh the
direction
that they go every day yes absolutely
they are a key part of this we they
actually have uh a group that actually
resides uh in the building here well
they share the the greater building but
they have a group group that that are
integrated with our staff and uh work
with us on a daily basis for that very
reason know we we don't do this without
them thank you that's great to
hear representative makoni thank you
thank you commissioner and others I'm
viewing a screen from 30 feet away so I
apologize um first of all I've got to
thank you uh Jim Gallagher and his crew
uh the job they did on the Osby Lake uh
uh work for our dam was just exceptional
uh Crews worked extremely well with the
town and we never had any
fluctuation whatsoever of our lake so uh
I can't say enough about that that kind
of ends my nice thoughts here so I have
a couple more questions so if you if you
could if you could help Mr chairman if
it's okay on the on the OneStop program
uh which has been absolutely wonderful
over the years a single Source a place
to go to to find
information and I have occasion to use
it myself uh almost on a daily basis uh
when the when the program went down when
the website shut down
I was disappointed how long it took to
bring subsurface back on uh but I'm
going to move beyond that so uh
subsurface Works inside one stop or is
the subsurface uh website separate from
one
stop it's a thank you representative so
it's a component of the one stop as I
mentioned uh that's why I use the word
clu so we have these these individual
systems that were uh created and the one
stop is the the connectivity if you will
for that uh and again I and I I I know
you said you'd move past that but the
the the system being down was not uh you
know desirable for from anyone one trust
me but again to give you an idea of that
so the the coding the SQL coding that
was done in those systems was the
problem so we were in a mode where
really so all that was so out INE
equated uh that they had to recode uh
all those systems to get those back up
and and running so they they wouldn't be
uh causing the problem they were so that
that's the the how far how far in if you
will uh the problems uh were so that's
why it took so long so uh our hope is
obviously never to be in that position
again which is why one of the reasons
why we're asking for these
funds and thank you and all the all the
people in it that worked on that so um
some subsurface are able to process
payment
directly but wetlands and others natural
heritage uh Bureau and others are do not
have that um and it makes it hard much
harder to do business and causes delays
and any part of this $5 million
investment um is Wetlands going to be
able to start processing applications
through uh similar to subsurface and
will will you in the near future be able
to process payments for
Wetlands certainly that is the goal for
all our our programs that that uh have
that type of uh functionality uh so that
is definitely our goal uh your last
question was what the timing uh is is
that correct representative yes please
yeah so I I don't have visibility into
that I you know my experience is uh
again we work very closely with doit uh
sometimes we contract some of the
workout and obviously the program staff
have to be spend a lot of time involved
with this my experience is uh I don't
trust estimates uh meaning they're
typically a lot longer so uh so my
experience is it takes longer than than
we are told and longer than we expect uh
so uh I I i' very be very hesitant to
make any promises though it is high on
our priority list thank you and one more
if I could Mr chairman last one y thank
you the um I understand uh or I hear
that the department is about to change
companies that process online payments
in the next month or two and if if that
is the case if you can just tell me if
it is or isn't going to happen and
number two are you assured when this
happens there will be a seamless and and
not a long downtime between
vendors so a couple things first of all
the department is doing that but it's
it's Statewide it's not Department did
not direct this so this is the credit
card vendor uh and my understanding is
that the time frame for that was
extended for another six months to
ensure that there would be an orderly
trans transition if you will and we have
people uh working on that coding as we
as we speak so that's our intention and
I think the six-month uh extension if
you will will help that thank thank you
for your time sir representative
edar thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you commissioner for addressing my
questions there were two matching funds
which were decreased from your request
uh the governor decreased them um you
seem to indicate that these type of
funds are over subscribed there there's
a lot of request form uh what's the
effect of not uh funding it to the
amount that you
requested yeah so again it's not an
ideal the the the fact that there they
made some Cuts there there but we do
think it's workable uh so if if it's all
right uh Mr chair I'll ask Sue Carlson
our chief operating officer to aine a
little bit on
that go ahead good afternoon this is
Susan Carlson speaking um yes um the
what I refer to is the haircut we got on
our um clean water and drinking water
srf grants um what it does is it will
delay our requests to to
um get the FY 23 Federal grant money in
the door until July of of State fiscal
year
24 so it what it does it delays our
ability to get that Year's Grant but it
doesn't eliminate our ability to get
it does that
help okay if if you're asking me I well
I assume that the uh uh Mr chairman if I
can continue
y um I assume you're going to be able
get able to get the request in but is it
just going to be
less um what is going to happen is
because the federal government is a
little behind in their
budgets we live on a time frame when
they announced that we can apply apply
for the awards once they announce that
um application period we only have a set
number of months to file the
application so what we will end up doing
is if we have insufficient funds let me
give you an example let's say they're
willing to the formula says they're
willing to award us $15 million and we
don't have enough match money on the
books to match the 15 we can either do
one of two things we can either apply
for less than the 15 million and apply
only for what we have match for or we
can
delay the application until we receive a
second capital appropriation in the next
biennium and apply for the full
15 so we will do what whatever it is
possible for us to do in order to get
the maximum money we can from the srf
program
and if I could Su sue if you could uh
tell me if I'm correct this type of EB
and flow you know small amount of
changes in the match is not you know if
you look historically that's sometimes
it's less sometimes we end up making up
ultimately we have to make up for it uh
in the future budgets uh so that's not
totally unheard of what we what what
we're seeing today correct yeah the
commissioner is absolutely correct when
we submit these capital budget requests
we estimate what the federal we think
the Federal grant award is going to be
for us for the next two
years um sometimes like we have um right
now we estimated low for fy21 and
22 um excuse me for
2021 so um approximately $2 million of
this request for
2223 is to allow us to get the federal
fiscal year 21 Grant in the
door once this is approved we have um if
this capital budget is approved by June
30th on July 1 we will apply for the
fy21 grant of $15.8
million and um and we will be in the
last three months of the application
period that allows us to apply for these
funds other years we have done this um
we have overestimated Grant request and
ended up cutting back on our grant
Awards um our history of capital
Appropriations as the commissioner said
has ebed and flowed depending on you
know what we are given for
Appropriations for match one of the
things that you should be aware of is
that the federal government does not
allow us to even apply for the funds
until we have match on the
books okay uh thank you uh Mr chairman
can I ask one more
question um on the slide that's right in
front of us number six is the water
quality and coastal
flooding um there was no explanation of
that in in the book because you didn't
you know put it in could you explain
that a little bit
please certainly so uh the items in
there were a new database uh $150,000
for new database uh for our limnology
lab
uh
344,000 for uh Statewide testing for
toxicants in fish and
shellfish uh uh
$53,000 for a new Mercury
analyzer and $350,000 for uh coastal
flooding modeling so hopefully that
hopefully that adds up to $844,000 I
think okay um if I could Mr chairman
this these items um they seem like in
some ways are fairly important with some
of the work that's going on now with the
coastal studies um I assume that you
originally asked for it because you felt
you needed it could you still use
it uh of course yes yeah we would never
have asked for it if we didn't feel we
feel we needed it but that's correct so
having said that we are not unhappy with
the current budget requests given you
know given the world we live in now
we're happy to get anything to be blunt
so thank you very much M commissioner if
you or one of your staff could give us
in writing what you just said about that
item I think members of the committee
would like to look at it as we begin our
deliberations we can do that
absolutely representative
able yes sir thank you um good afternoon
commissioner thank you very much for
being here and for all the great work
you folks do um I have a soft spot in my
heart for the solid waste Bureau so I
want to give him a shout out um I have a
couple of questions that's all right Mr
chair the first one is just with respect
to uh dams when you do your asset
management do you also look at whether
the dams um continue to be needed
because they do cost to uh they take
money to maintain and also in some cases
um our water uh would be better off
without being Dam so I just wondered if
you could speak to that or if your Dam
engineer
could all right well thank you for that
uh representative evil um so yeah I'll
pass off to uh whoever wants it that
either tomod donov or Jim Gallagher but
I will say uh as certainly uh those two
two on my my staff know uh that's a
question I keep asking too right so we
have a very large number of dams in the
State uh collectively not all most you
know only a minority of those are
state-owned uh and you know a question
is is it wouldn't it be better money
spent to get rid of the dam than to go
through these Cycles where you have to
put millions of dollars in to keep them
uh in the condition they need to be uh I
will say that's easier said than done uh
two things it cost a lot more money
generally to remove a dam than to fix
depending on what's going on up front
though I I I think a case could be made
that uh longterm is cheaper uh and of
course the secondary issue to that is
there are many people who for instance
uh you know if I was lucky enough to
have a home on that water body and you
remove the dam and I suddenly don't have
a home on a water body uh people get
upset if you will so you know so those
type of changes are controversial often
also so uh with that I don't know Tom do
you want to take that or do you want Jim
to take it sure thanks commissioner I'll
take that because it's actually a
multi-author review of that Dam to see
whether removal is a possibility
generally you know on a large Dam like
the one holding uh Lake op that uh
representative Maki mentioned obviously
that's not an option but in many cases
out of the 27 plus that we own it is
something to be very seriously
considered we look at we do have a very
successful relative both regionally and
nationally dam removal program we're
averaging about one a year or so and
some of them have been enormous success
stories like uh
um salmon Mills uh removal that involved
uh almost 15 years of work to get two
dams out that were integrated into a
mill complex and uh has now resulted in
subst anal improvements to those Waters
so there there's a short answer that
involves both water quality water
biology and the dams
themselves and and if I could could add
my name is Jim Gallagher and I'm chief
of the dam Bureau we do do that
evaluation we're faced with with any
either any repair project any project
needs to be repaired we also look at
that option of removal and we have
removed some state owned dams in the
past 15 years uh bunker Pond and eing
was removed did have a couple homes on
it but they got flooded during the 2005
and 2006 floods and they were glad to
have that out because the impartment
itself uh caused flooding on their
property uh the buck Street Dam in
Allenstown in Pembroke uh was another
Dam that we a state-owned dam that uh we
removed and it would certainly be a
component of the asset management plan
is take a look at how Dam that don't
serve any useful purpose
um as candidates for removal because the
life cycle costs of removing these dams
are uh less than the life cycle cost of
maintaining them and I just also want to
point out that one of the items one of
specific line items was to look at the
dams on the Mary meing River and these
are three fishing game dams this Mary
meeing lake is one Jones Pond which is
just
Downstream is another and the third is
what we call Alton power Dam I used to
have a power component to it all these
STS R by fishing game and in that
evaluation that we're going to be doing
is be looking at uh the feasibility of
removing one or two of them you know I
don't think we'll be moving removing
Mary meing Lake for the for the uh
reasons the director said it's you has a
huge Recreation component it's also the
water source for the for the Hatchery uh
but Jones Pawn in particular cannot meet
damp safety standards and that would be
a good candidate for removal but is as
the the director pointed out you know
there are um uh issues we wouldd have to
address with the community uh but that
would be part of that evaluation for
those marum
dams thank you very much um I have
another question Mr chairman if that's
all right yes go ahead thank you um
could so in the last budget uh cycle or
this $50 million was uh you know allowed
for bonding for pasas
matters which made us uh you know of
course we always watch our bonding
levels could you explain a little bit
more to the committee about that because
um we weren't really involved in the
discussions and you can say a little bit
about it I think it would be helpful for
us sure thank you representative and
again I'll I'll give her couple minute
warning that I'll I'll probably hand off
to sue Carlson again uh so yes so there
was last bium there was a a bill passed
uh to Grant a bonding of up to $50
million for uh the department to run a
uh a Loan Fund uh for uh regarding water
system impacts due to uh past contain
mination uh so we have rules that are
recently prated on that uh we do have a
couple request just uh recently came in
uh to to utilize that that uh new
program uh for the bonding and that's
what I'll ask to Carlson about uh the
bonding itself actually hasn't happened
yet and I think it's important for the
committee to understand obviously a lot
of discussion on that bill was on bond
rating and the the state treasurer was
was involved in those discussion
questions also uh the we don't see so
far no bonding has happened for that uh
and to the extent it does uh it's not it
wouldn't be a $50 million Bond it would
be to cover uh as as this program moves
forward so so so if you could add a
little bit more texture to that yes uh
excuse me yeah the um the bill that was
passed last year obviously allows um the
state Bond $50 million for the P Loan
program we have worked very closely with
the state treasurers office and and the
state controller and determining how to
do that bonding the decision has been
made that um they will bond um as they
do every other Capital project which is
we tend to bond the state bonds after
the fact so after we have spent the
dollars they will then Bond um whatever
portion that we have spent of our 50
million cap for that also just for your
um
own um excuse me excuse me knowledge is
built into that statute is um a section
that says if and when we have a lawsuit
against the manufacturers of Pas and if
and when the state is successful in that
lawsuit then the state will be re
reimburse for any cost associated with
the
bonding thank you very
much thank you any other questions for
Dees I do have one on slide three
commissioner on the uh dams that you
intend to work on is that your priority
list or is just a list of the dams you
hope to get
to I I I will again if Jim Gallagher can
correct me if I'm wrong it's it's not a
priy list per se uh and and you'll note
that I I believe it's a footnote too uh
that you know heaven forbid for instance
pick any one of these if if it happened
to be the sunset dam was our party at
the moment but the Jones pwn Dam have we
looked at it was you know an eminent
threat to to life and property you know
we would we readjust our priorities if
you will uh on the Fly for obvious
reasons so uh Jim can you add to any of
that or did I get close enough that
that's absolutely correct commissioner
um this is a group that um certainly has
a priority now based on their condition
in in uh in terms of the our entire
inventory 274 state owned dams but just
as the commissioner has said um uh we've
had the experience before where a damn
that's not even on this list has uh
developed um a a problem that needed to
be addressed mum's pond in barington was
such an example where we uh had a you
know couple three dams that we were
going to be getting at at that bium but
that uh that dam was showing real signs
of distress seat page was flowing
through the dam and carrying material
out of in the interior of the dam and so
we had to redirect our work to address
that very important Dam that high hat as
a dam uh was also important recreational
resource unh's uh Recreation areas on
there as well as a number of other
residences so that happens and we've had
a footnote on our capital budget which
allows us to do that to rep prioritize
projects um if the need
arises thank you um and you mentioned
that three of the dams that you were
looking at um are owned by a different
agency um are you going to get money
from them for the work or are we going
to continue to do it with general fund
BLS we have been doing work on fishing
game dams um uh taking respons we have
daily operation and maintenance
responsibility for those fishing game
dams Department of Transportation
Department of Natural and cultural
resources they have their own dams and
work that we do is largely funded by
those agencies
but in most cases not all cases but most
cases uh the work done on some fishing
game dams are done under our capital
budget requests thank
you any other
questions seeing none commissioner you
have any final comments no just thank
you and uh again Mr chair we'll get you
that listing of
uh that the the non the the items that
were not in the
the govern's budget request thank
you and with that committee we have
about 7 minutes until the next
presentation so the committee is in
recess until
1:45 thank you
I did find some of those um notes
[Music]
from
e
e e
coming
back back
up
um 12 works and highways committee back
in the session next presentation for the
capital budget is from the Department of
Corrections and I see that the
commissioner is with us already welcome
Public Works commissioner thank you sir
I apologize if there was some confusion
of whether I supposed to be physically
there or virtually here but regardless I
am here uh for those who I haven't had
the pleasure of meeting my name is Helen
Hanks I am the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections and the green
shirt and tie behind me is Jonathan
Hansen our administrative Logistics we
help co- facilitate this
presentation I'm gonna attempt to share
my screen not my
email can you see that beautiful
fantastic job well done on first slide
moving on we are the Department of
Corrections on the second page of the
presentation you'll see we tried to show
you what was proposed in the governor's
uh portion of the capital budget and
then the other projects that were not
included in the proposed funding to help
give an overall ask of what the agency
was projecting for
need uh at this point I'm going to let
John Hansen go into the detail slides
and help support him along the way but
he doesn't usually need much support and
then dive in whenever you need me back
thank you
commissioner good afternoon committee
good afternoon Mr chairman um on the
first slide you'll see that we have a
project to replace the existing Air
Handlers and duct work installed in the
medium custody North and South give ah
oh there's your mouse
sorry I thought I was doing on the other
screen
um in that slide you're going to see the
duct work in the medium custy north
south unit within the New Hampshire
state prison and conquered um that's
rusted and decayed to the point where
it's actually fallen down in the
chaseway um this unit was built for
actually um we have two of them
identical 285 inmates total we're
currently popul when the population's up
we're housing 570 people in there so
these air handles running constant 247
365 since 1983
the duct work is put in a Chase Way
which is also where the plumbing and
some other materials are and that's why
it's created some corrosion the way that
you see there so we are asking for this
money to redo the entire HVAC system uh
the heating and venting duct work in the
back of that
facility all
set that was actually priority number
two for us on the governor is priority
number one number two Governor's uh
priority number two this project is to
replace three cleav Brooks 350
horsepower boilers originally installed
in the big Renovations in 1983 these are
large boilers that typically typically
have a life expectancy of approximately
30 years we've gotten 39 to 40 years out
of them um we've been able to keep these
operational but they run again
365 247 365 to supply Steam for the
laundry and the kitchen operations we do
not shut these boilers down in the
winter time they go to High fire and
Supply heat for the entire facility of
approximately 400,000 square
feet this project will decrease the
state's utility consumption with modern
boilers the next one down the list
Governor number three are number five
this is the existing door control
systems of programmable programmable
logic controllers at ncf they have
reached their life expectancy
and by 2022 there will no they will be
needed to be replaced and we will no
longer be able to get the parts that we
need to operate that system and a modern
system will use a different type of
electronics and it will decrease the
state's utility
consumption project number four um for
those of you familiar the front part of
the prison was built in 1878 we utilize
the North and the South wings as areas
for education
for medical Etc there are heater coils
these are old copper type heater Co
coils and aluminum they're beyond repair
and leak into the South wings of the of
the facility the department is currently
soldering the leaks as they appear and
we're diver diverting water through
normal drip pans and drains but this
stop Gap measure will eventually become
ineffective and has already this project
will decrease the state's utility
consumption next project uh our project
number one Governor number five this is
the perimeter detection systems at the
northern Correctional Facility in Berlin
it's now 21 years old and needs
continuous upgrades to remain fully
functional the existing detection
systems uses outdated Technologies
difficult to maintain as they are
located in fenced areas with razor wire
the drainage systems that were part of
the original fence detection systems now
have sunken created sink holes around
the secure perimeter that have required
the doc to fill them in with will fill
but only as a temporary fix in order to
M maintain All Those sensors the
drainage systems need to be rebuilt and
the security fence system reset into a
dig barrier this project with the new
technology will decrease the state's
utility
consumption down the line You'll see a
picture here of what's called a it's a
muffin Monster uh or a sewer grinder
muffin monster is the brand name that
actually this is a request by this city
of conquered
this was a temporary uh location put in
1982 to put this actually almost within
Maguire Street which is the road leading
down to the old conquered electric and
um that area towards the U Smoke Stack
buildings so they've requested that we
relocate this into a heated building and
add an augur that's typical for an
operation like us because there a number
of things that could flush down the
system and all of that ends up going to
Hall Street which is a wastewater
treatment plant unless we stop it so the
project will combine three sewer lines
leading from the conquered prison into
one line making it more efficient and
reduce the amount of plug UPS within
their sewer lines this project will no
effect on the state's utility
consumption and we are down
to the
roofs the roofs on the Hancock and the
industries building as you can see from
an aerial slide there those have begun
to leak these are 30 years old and are
need of replacement um we use a 30-year
roof now which is warranteed and this is
obviously going to be what's going to be
replaced here this should have no effect
on the state's utility consumption
unless we're able to add some hard
insulation uh board to those
roofs so those are in fact the the eight
that were in the cap budget that the
governor
produced uh commissioner do you want me
to continue with the remaining ones I I
would prefer that we stop for a minute
and ask if any of the members have
questions on the projects that were
proposed in the governor's um Capital
Improvement Plan before we move on to
additional asks from from the Department
does any representative
Newman yes thank you um I'm concerned on
the let me see on the perimeter security
that got bounced to number five from the
governor's office and you had it as
number one could could you just give me
some background to help me understand um
why you had it as one but apparently it
did not get sold to the governor is
there sure so that's a perimet security
that comes with the initial facility
that was completed in 2000 what we found
over the last five or six years is a
number of components in that system
which failed it has a very old computer
connectivity back to the fence line
itself and then beyond that we had these
unsuspected sink holes along the edge of
the perimeter fence which was double
whammy because now only not only can we
not detect it but we have places where
there's voids the good news is uh as you
can probably imagine our own forces our
own electron shops and our own
maintenance techs are constantly staying
on top of this we have a perimeter
security patrol around the building all
night long 247 so we we're confident
that we have a a system in place but
clearly we need to upgrade that and
that's why that was number
one and representative Newman I don't
think it would be fair to ask the
commissioner or any of her staff to try
to guess why the governor would move
things around in a priority list um they
do work for him so I wouldn't ask him to
do
that all right I I just was concerned
that no that's fine thank
you representative
evil there there yes I'm here I'm I have
so many things I have to do at once I
wondered if I could um you could talk to
us about the HVAC system and if it is I
mean it almost looks like it's not
functioning very well and we've heard so
much about uh HVAC and
covid
and anyway whatever you thank you
representative AEL uh so this item has
been before uh the committee in the past
it it does not surprise me that it's at
least on the list to representative
Newman's question um and yes we were
mindful because of covid we had a a
third-party contractor come in and test
the air quality in both of those units
and again they they said it was still
livable but cautioned us that it needed
to be replaced and so again while you're
seeing it on the list of items that I
would hope to see continued support for
it would become uh problematic if it
continues in the situation it's in
especially in light of the covid-19
situation and other potential uh
Airborne infectious diseases but at this
time uh we'll continue to use that third
party um entity to come in and continue
to monitor the air quality so we can
ensure Life Safety in those units in the
meantime uh followup Mr chair
certainly um I just so will it have its
own internal filtration system or how
will that work yes the um representative
the the new type systems come with
built-in filters that are much more
robust than what was put in in the
initial U system that we have there as a
matter of fact those are similar to what
filters you'd have in your household
versus some that we have now they're 4
inch thick they're heap of filters right
and there's a lot of other things that
we'll consider during the design
including alteration ionization and
things like that within the within the
system itself and I think you your your
question is well put because we don't
know what that next generation will be
right now okay thank you we've learn
learned a lot about uh mves and hipas
and all sort
filtration thank you very much thank
you
any whose hand
is
Newman yes thank you on the lunch break
I had nhpr on and I I guess ironically
they were I I only heard part of it but
they were talking about the prison
system and I believe um what I heard was
that if you have to take some reduction
in monies coming to you that certain
educational programs will be cut and the
discussion on the r Newman we're talking
about capital budget not the operating
budget at this
point okay I'm my apologies I thought it
had to do with the capital budget I'm
sorry no and representative Newman feel
free to email me and I will assist in
any questions associate to the operating
budget happy to help you there
representative Mills thank you yes I've
got more of a follow-up question for
some of the older members on the
committee I know we finally allocated I
believe last bium uh monies for the uh
deplorable conditions that were in your
kitchen area and due to co and
everything I just wondered has any of
that been repaired is has that whole
kitchen area been uh
are been taken care of yes so uh first
thank you for funding that and uh
secondly it has not happened but I'll
let uh Mr Hansen tell you where we are
clearly some things such as Co and
construction being slowed definitely
interfered with that but I think we're
headed in the right direction now yeah
good question so that project 4.3
million was funded um we are now in the
final points of the of the approval to
get a design contractor on board we have
looked at at many designs to make sure
we can meet budget and build the kitchen
that we need to to do that many meals a
day which is between 5,500 and 6,000
meals a day so very soon you'll be
seeing coming before GNC was actually
scheduled to go in October um but that
agreement for the design will make it
the
GNC thank
you thank you other questions on what
was in the
governor's uh proposal
uh chairman I'm sorry Jack thank you Mr
chairman thank you commissioner uh if I
remember the discussion on the sewer
grinder last capital budget uh we had to
cut it because we didn't quite have
enough room to fit it and the city
wasn't very happy with you and I'm glad
to see it in there this time thank you
for that sir your memory serves you well
um I do want to point out to the
committee uh I must have talked too
highly of John he did miss one of those
items but I I still Top Notch that was
approved in the budget we just talk
about item seven on the governor's list
replacing steam lines and traps um I
don't want to lose that part of the roll
back to that slide I'll find that slide
and we'll brief you on
that thank you commissioner yes I
slipped right by that I puted on the
slide but I didn't know what I was
looking
at this is uh this is the governor's
priority number seven and our PRI
priority number three so this is the the
project to make repairs to the and
upgrades to the steam line and steam
traps at the conquered facility in some
cases dat back over 80 years this
project will not replace all the steam
pipes and all the steam traps but will
ensure that the system is sustainable
for at least the next 30 Years the Steam
for the conquer facility runs 12 months
of the year just as the boilers it's all
interconnected for the kitchen laundry
operations especially and then domestic
hot water in the winter months the steam
is our only source of heat for
approximately 400,000 of building space
many of these steam lines are old and in
the what we call a rickw well
manufactured pipe which is a direct
buried metal pipe with some spot welds
and they have lasted for many years but
now have succumbed to the elements the
welds have broken and a leaking badly
this project will decrease the state's
utility consumption
than any other questions on this portion
uh commissioner if you would like to
briefly go through what did not make the
cut um we are willing to hear
that thank you Sarah appreciate the
opportunity assume that these are in
priority
order yep if you go to uh the first
slide after our I'll bring it up on the
screen we put the doc priority order 9
through 18 um it was a continued ask uh
and and I believe we also have those in
the packet correct joh correct so there
are visuals in your packet we like to
show visuals I think it speaks thousand
words um this this committee's uh been
very supportive of our door replacement
uh project really ongoing to replace the
doors at the Men's prison and conquered
I'm showing you that uh slide we
continue to have doors that are rested
the locks problematic uh this facility
designed has a lot of exposure to
outward elements that the men's Prison
from the interior yard that ask was to
continue to replace a certain number of
these doors on
campus uh priority 10 for us was to
continue to look at again the men's
resident conquered and cealing repairs
um you know we tried to show you again
that ceilings and leaks and all of um
the different H HVAC systems and so
forth we've already mentioned impact
ceilings so we want to stay on top of
those issues within the facility
uh priority number 11 we're starting to
explore issues off the Men's prison
campus specifically looking over at our
probation parole office same street a
little further down on the right by our
store uh but that does not have a it has
a holding tank septic system so this
125,000 was to put in a proper uh septic
system and opportunities to have a leech
field and correct an issue that's been
identified during my time time as
commissioner anytime you want to chime
in and augment John you feel free to do
so we're masked up over here um moving
on to uh priority number 12 same
location uh dealing with roofing and
siding replacement same location again
um I think that's simply said showing
you imagery
there priority 13 we do have automotive
repair over on the Men's prison campus
um through going through that particular
space over the last couple of years this
is uh an asked to fix the floor drain
and repair some uh oil water separators
and things of the like in that space
this is the um auto body shop and what
we found is as an old facility that
actually is sitting in an area that was
from the 1878 version of the prism right
we we have a very old drainage system
over there we've had a little bit of a
scoping with some some uh materials that
we've seen go down through the drains we
want to make sure that they're
encapsulated in some oil water
separator okay and priority 14 as
previously presented was uh an area of
deficit post the women's prison
development and trying to come up with a
trades building this is a m the
construction John so this was uh the
design here is a is a standard type
building with a pitched roof which be
used for the woodw wood Masters and wood
training programs so vocational programs
at the women's prison when we modifi
things at the women's prison we just
didn't have enough room to include that
in the main building and we do continue
to work on Partnerships on the
vocational side to develop job skills
this is what this building would help us
accomplish and trying to promote
positive reintegration and reduce
recidivism for our
women priority 16 clearly a northern
Correctional Facility built in
2000 and no surprise we're going to need
roofs
there our job obviously in in my areas
to monit monitor these sort of things
we've gone up and those pictures will
show we've done some patching on our own
but this was prior to and as you folks
know Mr chairman your group mandated the
30-year roof warranty not too many years
ago that was um obviously long after the
the facility Berlin was built so that's
a 20-year
roof and then priority 16 are continued
roofs at the Men's prison and conquered
the roof
Replacements that's a number of roofs
commissioner that will be replaced a lot
of the roofs at the conquered prison
some of them date back a very long time
there's some pitches and some some other
areas that have run off we've inspected
them all it would be quite a project and
it will need to be done in time but that
did not make the
gun and then priority 17 we've done some
work at the northern Correctional
Facility to correct some hbac units uh
using our contract
uh during covid and and those have
mended them temporarily this is to
really go in and and create um some
opportunities to fix some hbac unit
Replacements up at that North Country
facility again we're at the 21st year of
its um use and that use certainly wears
on an
institution and then priority uh 18 is
to do some site work and
stabilization this was the result of
moving some land and and fill during our
women's construction phase of by our
training area yeah there were many many
hundreds of thousands of tons of rock
and um overburden that was moved up onto
the the top of the prow on the range at
the back of the women's prison um as we
got towards completion uh we did not
have enough money to do what Dees wants
us to do and that's to put in proper
drainage and swes we have seated in the
LOM some of it but more needs to be
done so that concludes what we
recommended and I'll stop sharing the
screen representative mcon thank you uh
nice to see you again commissioner the U
what was the price tag on doors and
locks item number nine believe that was
$200,000
sir and does that take care of your
total problem at this time we we believe
we'll hit the Lion Share of all doors
because we've already received 299 9,000
and that project is uh it's been bid
we're negotiating with the contractor in
the low bid right now so we believe
those critical doors will be fixed with
the remaining money thank you thank you
representative makoni um commissioner in
the past when we've had discussions with
the Department about how work is being
done within the
facilities there's been
some let's say discussion of about well
we're going to do it inhouse because
it's too hard to bring contractors in to
do the work how do you anticipate doing
a lot of these things that are both
either given to us by the governor or
what you're recommending you going to
try to continue to do the work in house
or you going to go out to actual bids
and get contractors
in thank you for that question and we
really want to Leverage The going and
getting a contractor in we do work with
that contractor when there's an
opportunity to use our staff um to help
either reduce the burden to the state
we're gonna we take that opportunity but
we certainly recognize that we need to
have our staff focusing on uh the
continued uh needs at TH those old
facilities so it's a primary use of
contractors coming in while leveraging
our staff to maintain daily operation
maintenance
needs thank you thank you um other
questions
Thomas uh
commissioner
um with respect to the septic system for
the trades building um is there not
sewer running by that part of North Main
Street by that yes there is uh
representative um so uh just jumped
right in I'm sorry no please because you
and I have talked about this go ahead
John so it's a great question I asked
the same one representative Thompson
when we uh when we were able to come up
with this latest estimate I personally
met with the city again the uphill
gradient would require pumping up to
their line so until we know for sure we
could potentially pump to their line but
their suggestion to us was to put a
leech field antiseptic system adequate
uh system on our
profit it's surprising oh go ahead I'm
sorry
sir um the problem is we have a 20-year
life on the septic system assuming
that's an
accurate um estimate and with the sewer
system if you put a grinder pump in your
existing holding tank seems like the
cost would be substantially lower to
pump up to the sewer and then the city's
problem once it goes beyond the curb
line not hours 20 years down the road or
depending on the type of system short
just to follow up so on on that uh our
preference has been always to go up and
tie into their line Public Works and I
work together on this and we were
surprised the city had suggested we
actually put this new type of uh a new
septic system in leechfield on site so
nothing's been decided yet but the money
is there to do either or that amount of
money will do either or okay thank you
very much apprciate
question representative a yes thank you
Mr
chairman thank you commissioner for
taking the question I just wonder um
because they're very much
similar if there's been any discussion
with administrative
services on these roof repairs and and
Replacements
whether whether you asked them or
um representative are you referring to
General services and their their workers
that do work on their own or their own
projects for roofs their projects for
roofs so admin Services Public Works of
course being part of that agency is
directly involved in these estimates um
if you're suggesting possibly combining
roofs and getting a better price for
more roofs that certainly could be
looked at by them
follow up yeah that's what my question
was because when we spoke to them um
they said you know
they when they were replaced or fixed
the ru that they have to prioritize it
and their estimates were based on um you
know what the scope of the work would be
when they you know
uh discovered what was underneath the
roof in
terms
the yeah exactly we we've had that
encountered on the last big roof
projects you folks approved for us we
had peins put in the gymnasium and
conquered we worked with Das on that and
we do combine projects with them like
our sprinkler projects typically when we
have to add four or five areas of
sprinklers we uh for fire suppressions
things we we combin with other buildings
so that is
possible thank you
thank you thank you for that question on
the roof Replacements both in the
northern correal facility and concrete
Are any are either of them currently
leaky yes um there are
leaks uh especially on the conquered
men's facility and we do patch and we
have a regular program in the spring we
go out and we use some sometimes
creative materials um to patch over you
know the ebpm type rubber membrane roofs
and we know that that does not last
forever especially when you use
materials that could eat rubber but uh
yes we do patch on a regular basis thank
you and so that the northern
Correctional Facility would
be um a higher priority than conquered
if a roof replacement was to be
funded commission I believe our our
discussion has been yes it would be
because it's a larger roof and when
there is a leak up there there's a lot
more square footage where the water can
get down into bad parts of that facility
um it's a very large flat roof conquered
we have pitched roofs in the second
phase the one that was not in the
governor's budget which need to be
addressed and some of those were simply
just adding B
drastics thank you and who's got their
hand up representative
Kinski yes thank you I just had one real
quick question
um I had a I've actually got a few
questions but I'm not going to bother
with taking up a lot of time today with
but I was wondering if I could get a
good email address forwarded to me that
I could email some questions about the
capital Improvement plan yes
absolutely all right so if somebody
could forward me that email
address um that would be appreciated you
had another one
Ben what's that you had another question
you said um no that's my only real
question for the group right now because
I've got my Capital Improvement plan
questions are there's quite a few of
them um and I don't want to take up a
bunch of time during that okay
representative Evo yes thank you um so
how are we doing as far as capacity in
the men's and women's prisons I'm
particularly in interested in the
women's just built
it our 224 bed facility for women we are
currently today at
136 and so we're certainly living in
that facility in a appropriate and
comfortable way which is nice that we
did not build it too big or too small at
the Men's prison uh today we have housed
1,244 individuals um that is definitely
down I will let you know I've seen our
population slowly decreasing at these
institutions over the last five years
that's a good sign uh but there're still
they've still all been with the
exception of women's been modified from
the original design capacity so we
haven't quite gotten uh to the place
where we can take out those I would call
them extra beds that were never intended
to be there representative able and I
can certainly follow up with some recent
information I gathered for division one
house finance and I'd be happy to share
it with the whole committee to show you
where we believe it was designed where
we are functionally today and it'll show
you uh the differences in design
capacity in fact um chairman I'll send
that to the whole committee I think
it'll be helpful for you to have that
information yeah I'd appreciate it thank
you thank you thank you for that
question any other questions from
members of the committee representative
mononi thank you Mr chairman um I know
who best to ask commissioner on on
Project number 11 that was explored
earlier the price tag on that
one yeah
one and uh if I could follow up on that
do we we own that building and do we own
the property that it sits on yes we do
sir we own all of that property and you
and if I could just to finish uh you're
working with h public works on that
project so if we had other questions
we'd ask them yes sir we are working
with public works on that project thank
you so much thank
you I would offer to the committee if it
be appropriate right now to let you know
that it looks like of um past projects
it looks like we have a lapse amount
that will occur of aund just well just
under
$153,000 uh dollars if there was an
opportunity
ex I'm sorry
$52,800 55 cents um there may be an
opportunity if at the will of this
committee that that money be deployed to
um some of these other projects that
didn't make the list but certainly I
know you have a lot of State
priorities and we thank you for that and
as you know in the past we have
harvested um money from projects from
all agencies to use on on projects
throughout the state so anything five
will be used for the betterment of the
state not necessarily your agency no
offense no offense taken sir but I
thought you would want to know that
opportunity existed and represent
smiling under here representative Jack
will be chairing a uh a subcommittee
looking at all of the uh lapses and
extensions of lapses so that we know
where we are on all of that before we
make any final decisions
thank you for that information yeah I
just want you to know commissioner even
though it might not be one of the
governor's High priorities on his budget
lists ever since we've uh our Public
Works committee came by and toured your
prison we've been very very big on your
door containers and very big that's one
of our priorities thank you I appreciate
your attention to
that and again happy to take people on
tours when it's safe and uh probably two
at a time would probably be the best
approach if there's anyone that has not
been in to see that um interesting
infrastructure architectural history as
I like to call
it representative evil yes thank you um
so I can't remember anymore if it was
last term we had an awful lot of
discussion about the special psychiatric
unit and what's happening with that I
know because of uh Financial con
straints we're probably not talking
about it right now but if you had
anything you wanted to share on that
subject I'd like to hear
it uh certainly representative AEL I
don't have any capital budget projects
Associated but I I do understand that
there's a bill that allocates uh there's
a bill proposed that allocates $8
million to build a structure on property
owned by the state near New Hampshire
hospital and I'll send you that bill
number um and if it if it's the will
committee I send it to all of you to
keep you informed of that much long
conversation is that a Senate
bill um or maybe you know about it Mr
chair and I don't I'm I've heard
something about what something was in
hille 2 that may be coming out I don't
know if Mr Shay can answer that question
at this point otherwise we'll have to do
some research but commissioner if you
could send it it would be appreciated be
happy to I I'll track that down for the
committee and send it out because I'm as
interested As You Are
separate the Civil committed from the
adjudicated would be nice yes you
clearly you know my stance on that
now thank you very much you're very
welcome any other questions for the
Department of Corrections about their
capital
projects seeing none um if we have more
questions commissioner I'm sure we will
be in touch with you or members of your
staff um especially if we go forward and
we do find some additional funds to
begin to look at some of your unfunded
projects we would probably ask you some
more
questions well thank you sir thank you
members of the committee it is a
pleasure to see you I look forward to to
being in person some of these days going
forward I wish you all well and I thank
you for your service to the state of New
Hampshire you
any member of the committee have
anything they need to share with the
rest of us or questions they would like
to ask me because I probably don't know
the answer but you can
ask again Mr chairman earlier today
under Department of CTE we I think we
should fall especially the situation I
would White Field just in case they do
pass it I agree uh hopefully everybody
heard what representative cluder said he
said we need to stay on top of and
follow what uh Whitefield is doing or
not doing about their CTE before we
finalize uh the house version of
hb25 um and not leave it to the Senate
to try to fix I mean I would think March
is coming up so they're going to vote on
sometime in March school district and I
just don't know when March 9th I know
was town meeting day some schools but
but I think we should try to I mean I
don't want to add my position Advocate
get it done frankly I have a vested
interest because next basically is
Claremont Newport which is not as of now
not until next by enum right you
wouldn't want to be competing with that
I I'd rather to get Whitefield out of
the way because I don't want Whitefield
if we can do it after the voters go
along of course representative
bunker thank you Mr chair um I took note
of what commissioner Hanks just said
about um tours of the facility um and as
a new uh member of this committee I
interested in that and I just wanted to
mention out loud so that if any other
new member of the committee would like
to join me um get in touch and maybe we
can set something up and and it is
worthwhile um you get a sense of
forboding as you go
in it is um a very old well um at the
time wellb built facility um the the
nicer one is to go to the North country
and go through that one but it's a
little further away
okay so any any member of the committee
who wants to do it too please just get
in touch with me
thanks so I see no other
hands all his questions regarding
capital budget just for the pris or was
it um hey Ben if you're there your
questions deal with the overall program
or just with the
prison uh my question were really with
the prisons and and I mean I'm curious
and I know it's not uncommon to see a
lot of 20 30 year old projects come up
all at once at the same time to have to
be worked on um but I was just curious
to see what they have in place for a
long-term capital Improvement plan and
how often that that's being updated and
monitored and how old some of their
other
with I the commissioner left her
email
um and it's in that packet I don't know
if you've opened it yet from Mr Shay
with the presentations but I will
forward you her um email address so that
you can ask those questions directly of
her and get that back um under statute
every agency is supposed to present
every bium a six-year plan uh to the
state for for look um but since we do
two year budgets you know how that works
yeah oh
yeah all right thank you very much not a
problem anyone else before I have Marty
pull the plug on this
um um work session of Public Works in
highways
comme just our next one is and our next
meeting it's in the calendar that came
out last night it is on the 5th of March
it is totally remote there will be all
of us sitting at home um and we have
several committees that uh uh agencies
that will be presenting to us um so
please look for whatever Mr Shay sends
out as far as
um the presentations by the by the
agencies and um we'll work from there
other than that you know how to get in
touch with me or the vice chair and I
appreciate everybody attending these
work sessions because once we're
finished with the work sessions and
public hearing we Dive Right into a work
sessions to plug numbers into
um any amendment that we may make to the
governor's
proposal and one final question that is
it starts at 9:30 9:30 on the 5th of
March you which is a Friday and I know
for some of you Fridays are not good but
with the lack of rooms and even Zoom
licenses I have to take what I can fight
for um and like taking away two days
this week from committees
didn't help at all for trying to get
work done for the entire house and it's
may only get worse over the next couple
of weeks as we try to
finish I see no further hands nobody
jumping up and down bar you un Just Want
to Thank You Mr chairman for good
meeting uh I try hard I I I learned from
several good chairs two of whom are
sitting to my right okay thank you